Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Es sind die Leute, die immer die neuste Technik am Start haben, aber die den ältesten Opening Song der Welt verwenden. Der Chaos Computer Club, heute zu Gast im Chaos Radio im Blumen auf Fritz, diesmal in Gestalt von Erdgeist. Guten Abend.
Wunderschönen guten Abend, aber nicht gegen Kraftwerk hier.
Natürlich nicht. Nein, das würde ich mir niemals erlauben wollen. Ich bin ja auch nur der Neue. Ich kann ja nicht. Nein, um Gottes Willen. Außerdem am Start Maha.
Ja, hallo. Kraftwerk ist genauso meine Generation.
Du darfst doch nicht so laut sagen. Und Nibbler.
Schönen guten Abend.
Guten Abend. Und es soll heute um Netzneutralität gehen. Das ist ja so ein schönes Thema, finde ich, wo der gemeine Mensch nicht fragt, mein Netz ist doch neutral, weil für die meisten Leute funktioniert das Netz ja so wie Steckdose.
Du meinst, es kommt einfach aus der Wand und funktioniert?
Es kommt einfach auf der Wand und funktioniert. Ich finde es, sehr geehrte Chaoten, wenn ihr näher ins Mikrofon geht, dann wäre das total großartig. Ah, genau. So, kommt aus der Steckdose, funktioniert einfach so. Und man hat die Idee, es ist so ein Netzwerk, da werden irgendwie Daten umhergeschickt und die gehen dann im einen Ende los und kommen zu dem anderen Ende hin.
Und zwar alle gleich. So, völlig gleichberechtigt.
Na, das glaubt man genauso lange, bis man von seinem Freund aus, sagen wir, den Staaten, so einen Link auf ein Video bekommen hat und sagt, klick mal da, tolles Video, dann klickt man auf YouTube und sagt, YouTube, ja nee, du darfst nicht klicken.
Ja, da muss man sich dann immer einloggen, weil man nicht alt genug ist. War das das, was du meintest?
Nee, das waren irgendwie die lokal beschränkten Angebote, wo man dann plötzlich nur noch als Amerikaner oder als Brite bestimmte Programme wahrnehmen darf, die dort von den Rechteinhabern freigegeben worden sind.
Oder Musik bei YouTube ist ja inzwischen nicht mehr zugänglich, wenn man aus Deutschland kommt.
Oder, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr Spotify kennt, diesen praktischen Dienst, der funktioniert wie ein Musicplayer, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass er sich alle Musik aus dem Netz zieht. Gibt es in Deutschland auch, kostet allerdings Geld. In Großbritannien gibt es eine kostenlose Version. Wenn man sich versucht, da einen Account zu machen, geht das nicht, weil er eine IP-Adresse erkennt. Ihr seid in Deutschland. Also so richtig neutral ist das Netz nicht. Aber das sind ja alles Dinge, wo man sagen könnte, naja gut, das hat halt irgendwie so mit Urheberrechten zu tun. Das kann schon mal sein. Gibt es denn auch andere Beispiele?
Na klar, gibt es andere Beispiele, wenn du mal versuchst mit deinem Mobiltelefon Sprachdienste, die nicht von deinem Telefonanbieter sind, zu nutzen. So Voice-over-IP mit dem iPhone zum Beispiel zu machen, geht einfach nicht. Da hat einfach der Anbieter was dagegen, weil der will ja selber mit den Sprachminuten Geld verdienen und da kannst du ja nicht daherkommen und dann irgendeinen anderen Sprachdienst benutzen.
Gibt es da eigentlich eine rechtliche Handhabe für? Also ich hab mich gerade bei diesem Telefon-Ding immer so, okay, ich bezahle doch jetzt für, keine Ahnung, 20, 30 Euro im Monat so eine UMTS Flatrate und ich bezahle auch dafür, dass ich da einfach Daten transportieren darf. Auf welcher Grundlage dürfen die mir verbieten, da bestimmte Sachen nicht zu benutzen?
Meistens in der Produktbeschreibung drin, dass man darüber webklicken darf und alles mögliche, aber bitte kein Voice-Over-IP und was ich noch viel schlimmer finde, keine Instant-Messenger. Wieso soll ich auf meinem Mobiltelefon bitte keinen Instant-Messenger?
Damit du deren SMSen einkaufst natürlich, die kosten ja auch Geld.
Ja, sie haben einfach mal nicht verstanden, dass eben die User-Experience, also das Konsumiergefühl, was beim Kunden entsteht, wenn er das Produkt benutzt, ein anderes ist, wenn er jetzt da seinen Instant-Messenger benutzt, wenn er sein SMS, also wenn sie da irgendwie Ersatz dafür haben, aber das sieht meist schon so aus, als hätten die, ja, das noch nicht so richtig verstanden, wie diese Nutzer das Internet so nutzen.
Aber sie dürfen es einfach verbieten in ihren AGBs, und da kann man jetzt auch erstmal nichts machen.
Ja, da können sie auch reinschreiben, du darfst auf keine ungeraden IP-Adressen zugreifen, sondern nur auf gerade. Die Frage ist dann...
Aber sie müssten es nicht mehr verbieten. Also stell dir mal vor, du würdest einfach Voice-Over-IP über dein Telefon benutzen, und die würden sagen, du darfst halt beliebig viel Traffic machen, aber der Traffic geht halt auch schnell rein, aber wird zwei Sekunden Zeit versetzt, einfach nur transportiert. Was das für das Telefonieren bedeutet, kannst du dir dann selber vorstellen. Dann hätten sie wahrscheinlich rein technisch und auch schon noch den Service, die die Daten zu transportieren, erledigt. Und würden trotzdem dir unmöglich machen, darüber Voice-Over-IP zu machen.
Okay, dann sagst du mal jetzt so, als ob es ziemlich klar ist, wer ein Interesse daran hat, das Netz nicht neutral zu machen, nämlich alle, die damit Geld verdienen können. Ist das so, erstmal?
Ja, das ist ein ziemlich guter Punkt, einfach mal zu verstehen, dass da, wo jetzt dein Internet aus der Wand rauskommt, ist nicht die Heilsarmee und ist auch nicht der Staat, der jetzt alle mit Breitband versorgt hat, sondern das sind Firmen, die versuchen, Geld zu verdienen. Und die primär versuchen, Geld zu verdienen, indem sie dir die Leitung zu verkaufen, wo du noch ein bisschen Wandbreite dazu kaufen kannst, wenn du ein schnelles Netz haben möchtest. Aber haben nach und nach auch erkannt, dass sie da eigentlich an einer ziemlich zentralen Position für dich so als Netzbürger sitzen, an denen sie sowohl wissen, was du wann tust, als auch steuern können, was du für welches Geld tust.
Und das Gemeine daran ist, sie steuern das nicht direkt. Also sie sitzen da keine Stoppseite vor die Nase oder sagen dir, nee, geht nicht, oder tauschen irgendwas aus, sondern die machen dir halt sozusagen die Milchsauer, die du trinkst. Also sorgen dadurch, dass sich das Internet in einer bestimmten Form nicht so toll anfühlt. Lass es zwei Sekunden Delay sein bei WhatsApp oder IP. Lass es langsam ladende Videos sein. Das ist halt für dich eine sehr subtile Möglichkeit, deinen Konsumverhalten einzuschränken, ohne dass du es direkt jetzt in erster Beschau auf deinen ISP, also deinen Internetanbieter, schieben wirst.
Der Chat schlägt gerade vor, man könnte das Internet ja verstaatlichen, aber das ist natürlich auch keine Lösung, weil der Staat natürlich auch gewisse Interessen hat.
Ah, halt, stopp. Apropos, ich muss jetzt kurz noch mal, das habe ich natürlich wieder vergessen, ganz am Anfang zu sagen, es gibt einen Chat. Das ist ja auch wichtig zu wissen für alle Leute, die vielleicht zum ersten Mal Chaosradio hören oder auch nicht so häufig dabei waren. Es gibt einen Chat, den könnt ihr entweder per IAC benutzen, das ist auf FreenoteNet im Channel Chaosradio. Falls ihr nicht weißt, was das bedeutet, was ich gerade erzählt habe, ist das gar kein Problem, ihr könnt nämlich auf fritz.de klicken und dort rechts, wo die aktuelle Sendung angepriesen wird, da könnt ihr klicken und dann gibt es einen Link zu so einer Web-Oberfläche, da könnt ihr auch ganz entspannt mitchatten mit anderen Hörern, die hier im Chat unterwegs sind. Außerdem stehen wir euch auch im Radio zur Verfügung und zwar unter dieser total altertümlichen Technik. Der Erdgeist kann die Telefonnummer auswendig. Erdgeist, Maha und Nibbler sind mich heute hier vom Chaos Computer Club, um über Netzneutralität zu reden. Die Leute, die jetzt die Telefonnummer, die gerade gesagt wurde, die wie heißt?
0331 für Potsdam und dann 70 97 110 Yeah!
Was dürfen die hier erzählen? Ich finde es ja z. B spannend mal zusammenzutragen, wo Leute schon auf nicht Netzneutralität gestoßen sind. Was da so viele praktische Beispiele gibt. Kann man da, also wir kommen erst hinterher dazu, wozu man das braucht und wieso, aber gibt es das überhaupt, dass man sozusagen sich Netzneutralität erzwingt, obwohl der Anbieter das gar nicht will?
Naja, man kann beispielsweise sich einen VPN liegen oder Tor benutzen, da ist das Netz gleich langsam überall hin.
Genau, VPN und Tor, das müssen wir kurz mal sagen. Das sind also beides Möglichkeiten, um eine Internetverbindung sozusagen indirekt zu erstellen. Dann weiß also der, der dir das Internet gibt, gar nicht, was du machst.
Grob gesagt.
Ja, also man nutzt den, der einem das Internet gibt, nur um da so Pakete, die alle gleich aussehen, zu einem Ort zu bringen, wo das Netz mutmaßlich neutraler ist.
Und das ist aber aus technischen Gegebenheiten total langsam. Ich dachte, das ist beides so.
Naja, bei VPN ist es so, dass man halt einen Endpunkt hat, zu dem man sich dahin tunnelt und dann das Internet von dort quasi nutzt. Und bei Tor ist es so, dass man auf eine breite Anzahl an Tor-Relays zugreift, die die Pakete untereinander weiterleiten. Und wo dann das Paket jeweils rausfällt für die jeweilige Verbindung, die man da hat, für die Seite, die man anlegt, das kann jedes Mal anders sein.
Da weiß man also nicht genau, wie schnell es ist. Beim VPN liegt es dann daran, wo man sich, also wo sein VPN-Punkt steht, d. h. wo man sich hineinwählt.
Das Schicke bei Tor ist ja, dass das Ganze anonym ist und schon aufgrund der Tatsache, dass das anonym ist, hat man halt keinerlei Einfluss darüber, wo man dann da rauskommt.
Aber damit nehme ich auch, neutrales Internet gibt es nicht oder wenn, dann nur sozusagen unter Einschränkungen. Weil es wird dann halt z.
Wir haben ja noch einige Dinge gar nicht geklärt, die wir schon ganz kräftig einfach in den Raum geworfen haben. Was z. B so ein ISP ist. Also, wo dann auf der anderen Seite, wo man gerade das Kabel in die Wand steckt, da lauscht da irgendjemand, guckt da, da ist ja so eine Kupfer- oder eine Glasleitung. Die geht zu seinem ISP und ISP heißt Internet Service Provider und das ist derjenige, der mit anderen, ja, auch ISPs oder anderen Endpunkten zusammengeschlossen ist und dann die Pakete ins Internet verteilt. Der guckt in die Pakete rein, wo sollen die hin und dann hat der da so viele Racks mit Rechnern drin, die den ganzen Tag nichts weiter machen, als sich jedes Paket zu schnappen, zu gucken, wo soll es hin und anhand von einer großen Tabelle, die er so hat, an seine Nachbarn weiter zu verteilen. Und dasselbe machen seine Nachbarn auch und dann kommt das hoffentlich irgendwann an. An der Stelle, wo es hin soll, entweder bei dem Server oder bei deinem Freund, wenn du irgendwie peer-to-peer machst, am anderen Seite bei seinem ISP.
Ist ja so grundlegend das Prinzip vom Internet, dass man da verschiedene Teilnehmer hat, große Netze, die sich zusammengeschlossen haben und miteinander Daten austauschen.
Also im Prinzip könnte man sagen, wir stellen ganz viele Rechnungen in unsere Wohnung, haben ein kleines lokales Netzwerk und legen dann noch eine Leitung in die Nachbarwohnung. Die haben das auch. Und dann tauschen wir Daten aus. Und das nur einfach sozusagen in riesengroß. Dann haben wir ungefähr das Internet erklärt. Und die Leute, die euch die Daten halt zuweisen, das sind die ISPs.
Genau, und da wo jetzt Kosten entstehen, was nämlich der spannende Teil ist, weil so eine ISP ist nämlich eine Firma. Und diese Firma nimmt ja bei dir Geld ein in Form von deiner Grundgebühr. Und sie muss Geld bezahlen für den Betrieb von den Rechnern, Strom, Abwärme, wissen schon die ganzen Kram. Aber auch die Leitung, die sie an die ganzen anderen Nachbarn, die Peers dort legt, der gesamte Treffig, der da drüber kommt, den müssen sie bezahlen. Und deswegen haben die so ein Interesse daran, den Treffig möglichst gering zu halten, an den Peerings, an den sogenannten Übergabestellen zum Nachbarn. Und das ist schon mal einer der Punkte, die für so einen ISP interessant macht, die Netzneutralität für dich zu verletzen.
Muss man aber kurz unterhaken, also nicht überall, wo Datenverkehr unterwegs ist, wird auch Geld gezahlt, z. B an Internet-Exchanges, wie dem Amesics in Amsterdam oder anderen großen...
What?
Das sind quasi große, große Switches, so wie bei Zuhause, der mit den fünf Ports, wo man seine Computer und das Internet dran steckt, sondern eben nur für Internet-Provider. Die können da kostenfrei oder gegen einen geringen Obolus für einen Port ihre Daten austauschen.
Okay, es gibt sagen auch die Möglichkeit, riesig große Mengen Datenverkehr auszutauschen, kostenlos. Aber letztendlich kostet es dem eigentlichen Internet-Provider Geld. Der ist deswegen daran interessiert, das Produkt so kompliziert wie möglich zu machen, weil er für jedes kleine einzelne Ding wiederum Geld verleihen kann. Also im Prinzip können wir sich vorstellen, wie früher die Züge, gab es die Fünf-Klassen-Gesellschaft, auf Stroh, auf einer Holzbank, auf einem Ledersitz und mit eigenem Keller, Kellner. Ich entnehme euren Worten, die ihr jetzt hier schon sozusagen zugehörigebracht habt, dass ihr schon ein Fan von Netzneutralität seid. Wir haben jetzt schon erfahren, warum Leute das nicht finden, weil sie nämlich damit mehr Geld verdienen können. Was ist denn der Vorteil von Netzneutralität? Also wer fordert das und was hat man davon?
Netzneutralität macht einfach mal, dass diese kritische Infrastruktur, dieses Gemeingut, eigentlich dieser virtuelle Marktplatz, also Markt jetzt nicht im Sinne von Handelsplatz, sondern wirklich der Marktplatz in der Mitte von einer Stadt, wo sich alle zusammensetzen, wo sich alle Leute treffen, dort unter anderem Handel treiben können, aber auch Gaukler auftreten, auch Leute einfach nur zum Tratschen hinkommen oder sich in ein Café setzen, dass dieser Marktplatz, dass der nicht künstlich reguliert wird von Zöllnen, die dort an den Stadttoren stehen und dort beliebige Zöller heben. Oder wenn die Zöllner z. B selber Schweine verkaufen auf dem Markt, dann niemanden reinlassen, der auch Schweine verkaufen möchte.
Also ich verstehe, was du meinst. Ich vermute die anderen zwei auch. Und für den Rest erklärst du es nochmal mit Skype und Handy-Telefon.
Mit Skype und Handy-Telefon? Na, wenn die Telekom nicht möchte, dass du Skype benutzt auf deinem iPhone, weil du ja dann die Gesprächsminuten nicht bei der Telekom einkaufst und dann einfach macht, dass diese Schweine, also diese Skype-Gesprächsminuten, du lieber bei der Telekom ableistest. Dann haben wir eigentlich genau die virtuellen Zöllner, die machen, dass dieser Markt nicht frei ist.
Ja, könnte man dagegen sagen, na gut, also bestimmte Sachen darf ich halt nicht oder kostet vielleicht nochmal extra Geld. Aber es ist ja ganz cool, weil dafür sorgen die ja, dass mein Netz toll funktioniert.
Es gibt einige kritische Infrastruktur, die man eigentlich nicht dem freien Spiel der Märkte überlassen möchte. Unsere Autobahnen z. B werden auch vom Staat betreut. Die sind die kritische Infrastruktur, die können alle benutzen zur Freizeit, können alle benutzen, um dort drauf Handel zu treiben, sprich ihre Waren durch die Gegend zu fahren. Und es gibt irgendwie schöne Beispiele, wo privat betriebenen Autobahnen einfach mal heruntergekommen sind. Man will eigentlich einige kritische Infrastruktur einfach den Staat machen oder zumindest regulieren lassen.
Also die Forderung wäre also sagen, das Netz muss so funktionieren wie diese Idealvorstellung. Alle Daten müssen völlig gleich behandelt werden und müssen von jedem zu jedem laufen können, es darf gar keinen Unterschied geben.
Das ist ja dann auch nur der Anfang. Also wenn mal so ein ISP Blut geleckt hat und sieht, ich kann mein Datenvolumen verringern, indem ich diese Netzneutralität ignoriere. Das kann ich beliebig weit treiben, kann ich Kosten optimieren. Wenn mein Kunden dann wirklich mal in MySpace oder YouTube klicken möchte, kann er sich das ja für 5 Euro im Monat extra klicken. Das ist genau das, wo es hingeht, wenn man dort konsequent weiterdenkt.
Das ist mal schon passiert. Die BBC wurde im letzten Jahr von den ISPs in Großbritannien angegangen, weil die ISPs dort schön Bandbreite teuer verkauft hatten, die sie eigentlich nicht hatten. Die ISPs haben da ja so ein Konzept, machen eine Mischkalkulation, die denken sich, legen wir so ein Kabel in ein Haus und da sind so 20 Wohnungen, und in diesen 20 Wohnungen wohnen 10 Omas, die eh nur zweimal im Jahr, wenn ihre Enkel da sind, Netz benutzen und ansonsten vielleicht so Durchschnitts- oder Intensivbenutzer. Und wenn jetzt plötzlich Leute anfangen, wirklich die Bandbreite, die sie eingekauft haben, da komplett auszunutzen, dann wird es da ziemlich eng, dann reichen die Leitungen nicht aus. Und die BBC hat jetzt ihre Inhalte vor zwei Jahren ins Netz gestellt, für alle kostenlos. Und plötzlich gab es Premium-Content in Großbritannien, den alle klicken wollten. Und die ISPs hatten dafür nicht mehr genug Bandbreite. Dann haben wir gesagt, liebe BBC, ihr macht uns da gerade unser schönes Geschäftsmodell kaputt, ihr füllt unsere Bandbreite aus, also bezahlt ihr mal bitte schön ein Obolus dafür, das wir euch nicht filtern.
Aber ist das sozusagen, ich versuche gerade eine Analogie zu finden, ist das so, wie wenn die BVG sagen würde, so Martin Gruppiusbau, bitte bezahl nochmal extra Geld, weil du so viele Leute in die Buster-Docs, weil deine Ausstellung so geil ist.
Genau, das ist genau das Modell und das ist natürlich wirklich nicht gut. Und ich meine, da kommt noch mehr dazu. Ich meine, wir müssen da wirklich überlegen, dass die gesamte Kommunikation inzwischen über Netze funktioniert und das ist irgendwie nicht so gut, wenn da immer einer auch mithört und gucken kann und mal so Inhalte auch austauschen kann, weil er vielleicht die eigene Werbung da reinschalten will oder so und eben genau beobachten kann, was jemand macht. Das ist ja natürlich auch das Problem bei der ganzen Sache. Der Internet-Service-Provider bekommt ja alles mit. Also ich kann mich von dem ja, wenn ich nicht irgendwelche VPN-Tunnel oder so benutze, erstmal nicht verstecken. Und das ist natürlich auch eher ein Grundproblem. Also es gibt eigentlich das traditionelle Briefgeheimnis, was es mal gab, als noch alles mit der Post verschickt wurde. Das gibt es halt so.
Na gut, aber die Leute, die Geheimnisse haben wollen, können ja wieder Brüche schicken. Wir haben jetzt 20 Minuten Chaosradio. Haben wir das Grundproblem jetzt geklärt? Ja, oder?
Ich hoffe.
Es gibt das Internet. Im Internet sollen nach Möglichkeit Daten übertragen werden. Und zwar so, dass sie alle gleich ankommen, sagt ihr. Und es gibt die Internet-Service-Provider, die sagen, na ja, vielleicht wollen wir da doch lieber noch ein bisschen mehr Geld verdienen. Und deswegen blocken wir bestimmte Dienste. Und wenn ihr die nutzen wollt, dann müsst ihr extra bezahlen. Was natürlich auch, das ist natürlich auch so ganz klar. Man kann natürlich sagen, hey, wir bieten euch ein total schickes Internet. Wir machen das sauber von allem Viren, Fishing-Angriffen, Spam-Mails und alles. Dazu müssen wir natürlich ein bisschen in Netzneutralität eingreifen. Und ihr müsst ein bisschen extra zahlen. Das wäre natürlich auch ein Modell. Da frage ich mich, was die Leute dort draußen lieber hätten. Also Internet, das richtig sauber ist und total gut funktioniert und dafür ein bisschen teurer oder so ein völlig freies, wo alles möglich ist. 0331 70 97 110 Und während ihr anruft und sagt, was mit der Netzneutralität... Oh Gott, wer hat sich dieses Thema ausgedacht? Netzneutralität los ist, hören wir die erste Musik im Chaosradio. Darüber beschweren sich die Leute im Chat immer so schön bitterlich. Nur deswegen machen wir das jetzt auch. Und zwar ist das alles Musik aus dem Netz. Die könnt ihr euch auch einfach so runterladen. Und zwar in diesem Fall von Cubism. Supersuit Mode heißt der Song. Und den Link zu dem Wiki, wo es die Links zu den Songs gibt, die findet ihr auf fritz.de. Der Anfang ist ganz schön fies, aber es wird dann besser. Tschüss View-Wissen, Super-Sued-Mo, das ist Musik, die könnt ihr euch runterladen. Und dass es Musik zum runterladen gibt liegt unter anderem daran, dass der letzte Mittwoch im Monat ist und das bedeutet wieder an, dass ihr gerade Chaos Radio hört und das heißt auch, dass Leute vom Chaos Computer Club hier im Studio zu Besuch sind bei Fritz, nämlich Erdgeist, Maha und Nibbler. Und es geht heute um Netzneutralität. Und was das bedeutet, erklärt uns der Erdgeist jetzt nochmal ganz kurz.
Genau, wir haben ja nämlich völlig vergessen mal so ein Maß anzugeben, wie uneutral eigentlich so ein Netz ist. Und dafür kann man mal so ein Extrem ansetzen. Und in diesem Extrem sollten Pakete, die im Internet unterwegs sind, einfach nur wirklich aufgrund von technischen Parametern durch die Gegend geschickt werden und nicht von politischen oder wirtschaftlichen Erwägungen. Und das zweite sollte sein, dass niemand in dieses Paket reinguckt, außer genau die Informationen, die dazu notwendig sind, um das Paket von einer Stelle zur anderen zu bekommen.
Nämlich die Zieladresse.
Genau, und das kann man sich zu Hause an so seinem Hub ziemlich gut vorstellen. Der Hub macht wirklich ein ziemlich neutrales Netz. Da wird ein Paket einfach draufgetan und überall gleich verteilt. Und der Hub lockt auch nichts mit.
Und das andere?
Kompletter Extrem wäre natürlich, wenn man, was nicht BTX, die Älteren werden sich vielleicht erinnern können, wenn man...
Nein.
Dann... vielleicht Nibbler.
Ich hab das schon verdrängt. Also BTX ist so was wie Videotext nur mit...
Also im Prinzip geht es auch darum, dass das Internet quasi total kontrolliert wird, also in allen Ecken und Enden. Man könnte sich so vorstellen, als ob man nur und nur ausschließlich das Online-Angebot, also die Webseiten von den Telekom, benutzen darf. Da gibt es ja alles. Da gibt es ja Musik, da gibt es Videos, da gibt es Nachrichten.
So ein redaktionell bearbeitetes Medium.
Man darf aber nicht raus. Zwischen den beiden extremen bewegen wir uns heute. Wenn ihr anrufen wollt und eure Meinung dazu sagen wollt, dann ist jetzt eine gute Gelegenheit.
Eure Meinung jetzt anrufen.
0331 70 97 110.
Diese Nummer gilt auch, wenn ihr Verständnisfragen habt, was ja ab und zu vorkommen kann bei Computerthemen oder etwas anderes fragen wollt. Katrin hat auf jeden Fall angerufen.
Also folgend würde mich interessieren und zwar, im letzten Fall, man ist Autonomalverbraucher und ist technisch nicht ganz so equipped, dass man wirklich dem so up to date ist. Also was ihr da redet, sind für mich echt bürgerische Dörfer, ist schwierig. Also dann hat man manchmal mal einen Euro lockern und kann einen Internet-Café aussuchen. Und wenn man jetzt irgendeiner bestimmten Peer Group angehört, einfach aufgrund deiner Interessen und so. Und also in einer kürzlen Zeit Informationen von A nach B schicken möchte, ohne dass man da irgendwie blockiert wird durch Sprach- Wahlsysteme und alles das, was auch schon angesprochen war. Und dann, ob es auch eine Möglichkeit gibt, einfach, ja, vielleicht, also ich hab mal gelesen, dass es OTA-Messagen gibt und dass es irgendeine verschlüsselte Form miteinander zu kommunizieren, sodass es, also gibt es da irgendwie eine Einwahl?
Okay. Also ich fürchte, die Frage, die du stellst, kann in der Kürze hier nicht beantwortet werden. Es gibt nämlich zwei Antworten auf diese Fragen. Die erste Antwort ist ja, es gibt sowas wie OTA-Messaging. Das ist eine Art und Weise, von Schlüssel zu chatten. Aber ich fürchte, das ist gar nicht das, was du suchst, weil was du suchst, was du gerade erzählt hast, hört sich an wie so, wo kann ich von einem beliebigen Ort der Welt mich ins Internet einloggen und dann ganz anonym und verschlüsselt mit jemand kommunizieren?
Na ja, also, na gut, im Grunde genommen ist es schon das, aber ich meine, wenn ich einen Anbieter gewählt habe, einfach weil der regional verschützbar ist.
Deswegen denke ich, es führt zu weit, was du jetzt fragst, weil es gibt nicht mal einfache Anbieter, sondern OTR-Verschlüsselung geht im Netz. Ich kann dir eine Empfehlung geben, wenn du OTR-Verschlüsselung mal ausprobieren willst, dann such mal bei Google nach Brain Invader, Pidgin und OTR-Verschlüsselung. Da findest du eine ganz großartige Schritt-für-Schritt-Anleitung, wie man OTR-Verschlüssel chatten kann. Alles klar. Machst du das? Bis dann. So, kein Problem, auch wenn die Frage mal ein bisschen ab vom Thema ist, wir beantworten sie trotzdem gern, oder Jungs? Ja, dachte ich mir doch.
Die Wikipedia gibt auch gute Auskunft mit Link über OTR-Messaging.
Alles klar, bevor es aber weitergeht mit euren Fragen, Netzneutralität und den, können wir das anders nennen? Gibt es ein anderes Wort für Netzneutralität?
Netzneutralität.
Gibt es da ein Wort, das das Gegenteil ausdrückt? Ich suche da immer noch irgendwas und das ist ein sehr gutes Zeichen.
Diktatorennetz. Tyrannennetz. Wir klären das nachher. Jetzt gibt es erstmal Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Super Radio 3000, wir spielen die größten Super-Mega-Hits aller Zeiten mit der meisten Abwechslung und dem besten von heute im Super-Mega-Mix. Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich bin's, Rocky King, der Product Manager von Hit Music Productions.
Interessant.
Wir haben einen super Hit gemacht. Ich spiele es mal an.
Happy Happy Music.
Den Song würde ich gerne bei euch auf der Hot Rotation sehen. Zwölf bis fünfzehnmal am Tag.
Interessant.
Ja, das wird man uns natürlich auch was kosten lassen.
Interessant, verstehe. Da verbinde ich sie gerne mal eben mit unserer Marketingabteilung.
An dieser Stelle wollen wir mal kurz darauf hinweisen, wie wichtig es ist, dass es Radioprogramme gibt, die von Musikindustrie und Hit Music Hit Produzenten unabhängig sind. Unabhängig sind. Und die man für Geld nicht kaufen kann.
Das ist der Überhit. Das ist magic. Da klingeln die Kossen.
Ist ein öffentlich-rechtliches Radioprogramm. Und abhängig sind wir auch. Powered bei eure und Funkebühren.
Um halb elf.
Nachrichten.
Mit Mario Bartsch.
Nach dem schweren Seebeben vor Indonesien befürchten die Behörden, dass mehr als 1000 Menschen ums Leben gekommen sind. Aktuell ist von 75 Toten die Rede, allerdings werden noch tausende Menschen unter den Trümmern vermutet. Durch das Beben heute vor Sumatra waren auf der Insel zahlreiche Häuser eingeschaltet. Erst gestern hatte ein Seebeben den südlichen Pazifik erschüttert und einen Tsunami ausgelöst. Dabei starben mehr als 120 Menschen. In Stuttgart wurde heute darüber beraten, wie Amokläufe an Schulen in Zukunft verhindert werden können. Ein Expertenteam hatte Vorschläge erarbeitet, wie Schulen sicherer gemacht werden sollen. Die Fachleute empfehlen z. B ein spezielles Türsystem für Klassenzimmer, bei dem sich im Ernstfall die Tür nur noch von innen öffnen lässt. Für Jugendliche wurde außerdem ein generelles Verbot von sogenannten Killerspielen vorgeschlagen. Ob die rund 80 Vorschläge auch umgesetzt werden, ist aber noch nicht klar. In Berlin und Brandenburg sind wieder weniger junge Leute arbeitslos. Laut Bundesagentur für Arbeit ist die Zahl im Vergleich zum August um 6000 zurückgegangen. Derzeit sind somit 46.000 Leute unter 25 in der Region arbeitslos gemeldet. Der Grund für den Rückgang ist vor allem der Beginn des Lehrjahres. Dadurch fallen wieder viele Azubis aus der Statistik raus. Auch in ganz Deutschland gab es im September weniger Arbeitslose. Insgesamt hatten 3, 3 Millionen Menschen keinen Job. In der Fußball-Champions League muss Bayern München heute Abend gegen Juventus Turin ran. Dort steht es kurz vor Ende 0 zu 0. Außerdem spielt Wolfsburg bei Manchester United. Wolfsburg liegt 1 zu 2 zurück. Heute Nacht ab und zu Regen, bei tiefsten Temperaturen zwischen 12 und 8 Grad. Am Tag dann erst viele Wolken und auch ein bisschen Regen. Nachmittags lockert es etwas aus. Auf muss es natürlich heißen, es sind aber trotzdem vereinzelt Showermöglich. Höchstwerte 13 bis 15 Grad. 24 Hamburg Richtung Berlin zwischen Mainburg und Pritzwald gab es einen Unfall mit einem LKW. Dort ist die Richtungsfahrbahn gesperrt. Fahrt da vorsichtig ans Staueende heran. Sonst überall. Gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5, dann Fritz in Frankfurt Oder.
Im Chaos Radio mit Marvis Hüster und zwei, drei, vier, 98.000 Leuten vom Chaos Computer Club, Erdgeist, Marhau und Nibbler sind bei mir, um über... Kannst du aufhören Scherze zu machen, die keiner versteht? Jetzt musst du es erklären. Re was?
Re sagt man im Chat, wenn man wieder zurückkommt, nachdem man sich verabschiedet hatte.
Wir sagen Rehigh und es geht heute um Netzneutralität. Das bedeutet, dass die Daten im Netz einfach so durchgeschickt werden. Und das Gegenteil, wir haben uns gefragt, gibt es ein Wort, was das Gegenteil ist? Im Chat kamen folgende Worte, wurden vorgeschlagen. Im Chat zur Sendung, den ihr auch klicken könnt, wenn ihr fritz.de klickt.
Quality of Service, passt das?
Hat das was damit zu tun? Oder ist das Gegenteil?
Nein, das ist nicht genau das Gegenteil.
Was ist Quality of Service?
Das hat was damit zu tun, aber das ist nicht unbedingt ein Gegenwort dazu. Quality of Service bedeutet, dass man an seine Pakete heranschreibt, wie wichtig es einem ist, dass das Paket transportiert wird. Wenn ich jetzt z. Internet-Telefonie habe, dann kann ich da drauf schreiben, das ist bitte so dringend wie nötig zu behandeln. Wenn ich jetzt ein Download habe, dann ist mir das relativ egal, wann da meine Daten kommen, Hauptsache sie kommen irgendwann mal. Wenn ich jetzt eine Leitung habe, die mit beiderlei Paketen voll ist, dann werden die Pakete mit der Internet-Telefonie vorzug behandelt, weswegen sich das dann super anhört, dass dann der Download ein bisschen langsamer ist, stört einen dann kaum.
Oder auch viel spannender ist natürlich, wenn man gerade seine Konfliktsimulations-Lösungsspiele wie Quake oder so spielt, dann möchten natürlich die Pakete zum Quake-Server dort auch schneller ankommen, als die Pakete, die man von Spiegel bekommt.
Das war jetzt die technische Definition von Quality of Service.
Gibt es noch eine andere?
Na ja, Quality of Service ist auch ein Argument, die Leute sagen, wir möchten also unsere Qualität erhöhen. Wir möchten für die Nutzer das Netz flexibler gestalten und sagen dann, ja, das ist eben jetzt das Quality of Service Netz, wo wir Qualität anbieten. Das bedeutet aber, es ist nicht mehr neutral.
Da kann man sich jetzt streiten, ob man sagt, dass so ein nicht-neutrales Netz eigentlich ganz gut ist, wenn der Internet Service Provider die richtige Entscheidung für einen trifft und sagt, okay, das ist Internet-Telefonie-Traffic, den behandele ich jetzt mal besser, das andere ist was anderes, das behandele ich schlechter. Also, die Hafer, die sie da einsetzen, das Equipment, was man heutzutage hat, um Pakete zu klassifizieren, um in so ein Paket reinzugucken und die Aussage treffen zu können, was ist da in dem Paket drin. Und auf der...
Ich möchte ganz kurz noch mal was sagen, auch für den Fall, als alle Leute, die jetzt Ahnung von dem Teil haben, sagen, nein, nicht schon wieder erklären, aber weil ja andauernd von Paketen die Rede ist und wir über das Internet eigentlich reden, das zu sagen, nur um es noch mal zu sagen, es ist halt schon so, dass der Datenschrub im Internet unterteilt ist in viele kleine Einheiten und Leute, die Ahnung davon haben, sprechen in diesem Fall von Paketen. Man kann sich tatsächlich sozusagen vorstellen, wie bei der Post gibt es so kleine Dinge, die durchgereicht werden. Und wie guckt man da jetzt rein, um zu sagen, hier, was bist du, würde ich dich jetzt weitergeben oder nicht?
Naja, im Jahr 2009, da ist das mit dem Internet ja schon der technische Fortschritt hinreichend weit gedient, dass man inzwischen Geräte bauen kann, die in Pakete reingucken, nicht nur eins, sondern ganz viele Pakete in kurzer Zeit und eine Entscheidung treffen können, was ist in dem Paket drin, wie behandele ich das jetzt, also den Datenverkehr zu klassifizieren, zu sagen, das ist ein Download, das ist Telefonie, das hier ist eine E-Mail und was auch immer. Und so wird quasi aus den Paketen die darüber liegende Logik wieder rekonstruiert. Also der Router, der diese Pakete weiterleitet, guckt sich dann nicht nur das Paket an und guckt auf die Empfängeradresse, sondern schaut eben, was ist denn das überhaupt, und guckt dann neben der Empfängeradresse immer nach, was er dann damit noch so tun soll.
Das heißt dann, indem sich der Typ, der uns das Internet anbietet und zur Verfügung stellt, anguckt, was für einzelne kleine Pakete wir versenden, weiß er dann jetzt endlich genau, was wir gerade machen.
Ja, da brauchst du dich gar nicht die Pakete angucken. Der sagt einfach dem Equipment, was da steht, ich möchte, dass meine Nutzer keinen Bit-Torrent mehr nutzen können, oder ich möchte, dass meine Nutzer kein Internet-Telefonie mehr nutzen können, und das macht die Hardware dann von selber.
Ja klar, aber sozusagen im Auftrag der Firma, im Auftrag des Internet-Providers. Ich möchte mich jetzt da nur mal der Theorie wegen auf den Schampen stellen. Ich finde es eigentlich eine gute Sache, wenn das so passiert, weil dann ist ja mein Internet schneller, wenn der ganze Dove-Bitt-Torrentreffig verboten wird. Mal schauen, was Ulf dazu sagt.
Also grundsätzlich bin ich auch für Netzneutralität. Und wir haben das alles so unheimlich hochgejubelt. Das Internet mit den ganzen neuen Dingen, Copy left und so weiter, sofort. Und jetzt merkt man so nach und nach, verändert sich dieses Verständnis immer mehr. Ich hatte mir vorhin auch Quality of Service und diese Deep Packet Inspection angeguckt und aufgeschrieben. Das ist nämlich genau der Punkt, dass sich das jetzt so Step by Step verändert. Beton wird jetzt erst schlecht oder dann verboten oder gedrosselt oder sonst was. Also das heißt, man kann ganz deutlich sehen, dass sich das jetzt scheinbar nach und nach wieder einzudämmen scheint. Und das Internet, was ja irgendwie so zukunftsträchtig sein soll und so das schlechthin sein soll, weil es ja so frei ist, jetzt so heimlich über die Hintertür wieder zugemacht wird. Also so peu à peu eingeschränkt wird. Und jetzt war vorhin, gerade in der Werbung, diese Geschichte, es soll auch Sender geben, die unabhängig von der Musikindustrie seien. Das war ja genau kurz vor den Nachrichten diese Werbung. Man kann nur sagen, dass das, was bis dato redaktionell behandelt wurde, nach und nach eingegangen ist. Ich meine, dass AOL mal am Anfang sowas gemacht hat. Und alle anderen Geschichten sind sicherlich auch nicht in der Form so groß geworden. Also ich weiß nicht, Tee Online wird sicherlich viel besucht, aber... Ja, genau, eben aus dem Grund. Bis dato hat sich aber gezeigt, dass so alles, was so frei war, also ich meine, das Fernsehen hat riesige Schwierigkeiten, gegen das Internet zu bestehen, weil die Leute scheinbar irgendwie im Internet Dinge suchen, die sie im Fernsehen nicht finden können. Oder nicht in der Freiheit finden können. Also zeigt das aber irgendwie ganz deutlich, dass die Leute anscheinend nicht redaktionell bearbeitete Inhalte haben wollen. Selbst die Radios haben wohl damit Schwierigkeiten, aber das kann ich ja nicht sagen, weil ich jetzt gerade bei solchen Anrufen... Und nichtsdestotrotz, viele Leute sehen die GEZ als extrem wichtig, also was ich nicht mehr unbedingt als so wahnsinnig wichtig empfinde, gerade aus dem Gedanken heraus, dass es die Vielfalt geben soll. Es soll viele Sender geben und so weiter und so fort. Und diesen Leuten dann zu verklickern, dass das Internet im Prinzip in die gleiche Richtung geht, ist nahezu unmöglich. Also ich hatte mich vorhin mit einem Kumpel unterhalten, der genau das sagte. Kurz bevor wir uns über diese Sendung unterhalten haben, sagte er, na ja, also den Nerds zu erklären ist nicht mehr nötig. Aber den Leuten zu erklären, na ja, dem ganz normalen Kumpel zu erklären, wie willst du das rüberbringen? Wie willst du den Leuten erklären, das mag dich jetzt nicht stören. Dein Provider bietet dir an, dass es dieses Fast Pass gibt. Da kann man irgendwie einen Euro mehr für zahlen. Das wäre übrigens so meiner Meinung nach eine der ersten Sachen, die genau so dann rübergebracht wurden. Also für die man dann bezahlt hat.
Na ja, das war alles gleichmäßig schneller. Also der technische Hintergrund ist der, dass du dann bei der Datenübertragung ein bisschen vieler toleranter bist, dir dafür aber Laufzeit einsparst. Also einfach nur ein Konfigurationsparameter. Aber du hast im Grunde schon recht. Also es kommt über die Hintertür. Also die fehlende Netzneutralität wird sich nicht von heute auf morgen bemerkbar machen, sondern das kommt ganz langsam. Wenn man sich da mal aktuelle Entwicklungen anguckt, es gibt den einen oder anderen Internet-Service Provider, die momentan schon in den Abendstunden ihren Traffic, also ihren Internetverkehr, durch so Paketklassifizierungsgeräte laufen lassen. Und man hat bei so einem Internet-Provider immer so eine Sinusartige Kurve, die nimmt, je nachdem, ob das jetzt ein geschäftlich genutzter oder ein vornehmlich privat kundenlastiger Anbieter ist, hat man so abends einen relativ hohen Berg und nachts so gegen vier bis sechs ist das im Tal. Und die ersten Internet-Provider fangen schon an und setzen ihr Limit für die Gesamtbandbreite irgendwo knapp unterhalb dieser oberen Grenze dieser Kurve und schneiden da einfach mal den Berg an Internetverkehr, der zur Stoßzeit ankommt, ab und sagen, Gesamtbandbreite drosseln wir an der Stelle mal, aber wir machen es nicht für alle gleichgangsam, sondern wir gucken uns da an, was unsere Nutzer an Daten transferieren. Und dann ist das bithorent zur Stoßzeit halt etwas langsamer. Webklicken geht genauso schnell. Das ist so ein schleichender Prozess.
Da muss man mal ganz ehrlich sagen, auch die Frage an Ulf, wenn ich jetzt zu Hause sitze und sozusagen im Netz surfe, dann merke ich so, okay, 20 Uhr, alle anderen Leute tun das gerade auch. Sag mal, Ulf, hast du deinen Radl noch an? Komische Rückkopplung hören wir hier.
Nee, ich hab sogar den Lautsprecher komplett abgeschaltet.
Dann muss ich mal kurz hier so, also die Leute surfen halt alle abends und dann sagt man so, okay, der Typ, der sich jetzt in meinem Haus auch das dicke Bithorn saugt, der macht mir gerade die ganze Leitung dicht und ich krieg einfach nichts mehr hin. Jetzt ist es bei dem ja nicht so wichtig, dass er irgendwie heute Abend noch seine Serie oder sein illegal heruntergeladenes Album komplett zu kriegt. Wäre es dann nicht eigentlich fair zu sagen, okay, wir drossen den Bithorn jetzt mal runter, damit alle Leute übrigens noch surfen können?
Nee, was steckt da nicht dieser Gedanke hinter? Freiheit ist nicht fühlbar. Nur das nicht Vorhandensein von Freiheit ist fühlbar. Also mit anderen Worten kommen wir doch genau dahin. Was bedeutet das denn? Ich möchte mir jetzt mitunter Musik downloaden. Oder ich hatte in Australien, habe ich mir viel vom Chaos Computer Club diese ganzen Videos downloadet und habe da massiv Schwierigkeiten gekriegt durch diverse Filtermethoden und so weiter, völlig legaler Content. Na ja, sicher, klar, da würde ich mitunter, also da wird meine Freiheit eingeschränkt und jemand anders definiert, dass diese Freiheit mir nicht zugestanden werden soll. Aus diversen Gründen. Na ja, dann ist die Frage, wo setzen wir denn das Minimum an Freiheit an? Also wie tief müssen wir runter, dass es für uns alle dieser Gedanke dann noch passt? Weil irgendjemand wird immer noch was dagegen haben und sich in seiner Freiheit eingeschränkt fühlen, schneller surfen zu können. Also mit anderen Worten wird das Ganze immer schön weiter nach unten geschackelt und die Internetanbieter werden sich dagegen nicht wehren. Die Kalkulation geht dann immer besser auf.
Du meinst also sagen, es geht nur komplette Netzneutralität und sonst funktioniert gar nichts?
Na gut, ich meine, die Katze beißt sich so in den Schwanz, dass ich natürlich auch möchte, dass ich irgendwann mal telefonieren kann. Also das heißt, Quality of Service ist an und für sich ja eine gute Idee. Die Problematik liegt daran, dass da Menschen hinter sitzen. Und Menschen sind grundsätzlich, sagen wir, nicht unbedingt neutral. Also die werden ihre Interessen durchsetzen. Und da meine Interessen nicht mit den Interessen meines Anbieters übereinstimmen, werde ich da auch an dem Punkt grundsätzlich Schwierigkeiten kriegen. Also ist die Frage, ob ich wirklich Quality-of-Service will oder nicht lieber akzeptiere, dass nicht unbedingt alles zu allen Zeiten geht. Und dafür aber dann sicher sein kann, dass es nicht korrumpiert wird.
Okay, wenn du jetzt vor die Wahl gestellt würdest, dann würdest du auch genau das wählen? Ulf würde sagen...
Würdest du dafür auch mehr bezahlen wollen, Ulf? Oder wäre dir was wert, für ein ungefiltertes freies Internet mehr Geld auszugeben?
Da ist natürlich dann die Frage, wie viel an und für sich schon. Also die bewusste Wahl eines Internetanbieters, der beispielsweise keine Voice-over-IP-Geschichten macht und so weiter, also eine richtige Leitung macht, das ist jetzt schon realisiert. Also das heißt, die Idee dahinter, ordentliche Leistung zu bekommen, die nicht beschnitten wird, die nicht eingeschränkt wird und so weiter in dem Falle...
Ja, aber lass uns mal eine Nummer hypothetischer machen, also sagen nicht irgendwie, welche Anbieter, sondern dein Internet-Anwärter sagt dir in Zukunft ganz klar, pass auf, entweder du kriegst für einen Zehner so viel Internet, wie du nur versurfen kannst, aber bitterend ist extrem langsam und Voice-over-IP geht nur von 22 bis 6 Uhr. Kostet dafür aber nur einen Zehner und für 35 Euro kriegst du ganz ungefiltertes Internet. Jetzt irgendwie die Preise mal ausgedacht. Was würdest du dann nehmen?
Nee, gut, also das liegt noch durchaus im Rahmen. Und was will ich mit einem Internet, also das Letztere, und was will ich mit einem Internet, was ich faktisch nicht nutzen kann?
Okay, also Ulf will unbedingt ein freies Internet, würde sich das auch was kosten lassen. Wenn ihr dazu auch eine Meinung habt und es vielleicht sogar anders sieht, dann...
Jetzt anrufen!
0331 70 97 110 Mal gucken, ob Björn da anders tickt. Hallo Björn.
Hallo, nein, ich tick genauso.
Okay.
Also ich bin auch der Meinung, dass es zwar keine Alternative zur Netzneutralität gibt, weil alles andere zu einem Aufrüsten auf Seiten der User führen würde, was dann so einen hochschaukelnden Effekt hätte. Das weiß ich dann. Dann wird eben ein Peer-to-Peer-Protokoll entwickelt, das über verschlüsselte ODP-Pakete auf verschiedenen Ports funktioniert.
Das kann man gleich sperren.
Genau. Und wenn das dann irgendwie dann noch gesperrt wird, deckt man halt wieder irgendwas Neues aus. Das macht höchstens das Internet kaputt, indem man da eben mehr Ports an seinem heimischen Router freischalten muss und dadurch Sicherheitslücken aufmacht.
Also ich glaube, wenn wir das jetzt alles erklären müssten, was du gerade gesagt hast, dann würden wir ein bisschen länger brauchen. Aber du sagst im Prinzip, wenn es keine Netzneutralität gibt, dann denken sich die Leute halt immer was Neues aus und das wird dazu, dass wieder noch mehr eingeschränkt wird und dann haben wir so ein Wettrennen.
Ganz genau. Und auf der anderen Seite geht eben das Internet kaputt, weil eben die Prinzipien, nach denen es mal erdacht worden ist, einfach blockiert werden.
Plus du hast ja dann dadurch schon wieder Kosten. Also wenn du auf deiner Seite aufrüsten musst, wenn du da vielleicht wieder einen Endpunkt für deine VPN-Verbindung suchen musst, die dir ein richtiges Internet macht, dann sind das wieder Kosten, die du auf deiner Seite anfangen kannst. Du kannst ja gleich sagen, na gut, dann bezahle ich halt ein bisschen mehr für ungefiltertes Netz.
Ja, das würde ich auf alle Fälle tun, dass mehr für ungefiltertes Netz bezahlen. Wobei ich dann diese Zweiklassengesellschaft im Internet nicht befürworten würde. Die, die weniger bezahlen, eben dieses kastrierte Internet bekommen und die, die ein bisschen mehr bezahlen können, dann das Vollwertige. Das finde ich nicht in Ordnung. Das widerspricht meiner Ansicht nach auch gegen die Netzneutralität, dass jeder den gleichen Zugang hat.
Oh, dass jeder den gleichen Zugang hat. Das ist ein spannender Punkt, weil die andere, die vorhin hier war, die hat gemeint, sie müsste ins Internetcafé gehen, um dort Internet zu haben. Und ich finde das heutzutage, wo man eigentlich am gesellschaftlichen Leben ohne Internet gar nicht mehr so richtig teilnehmen kann, so zur Netzneutralität natürlich auch dazu gehört, dass jeder bei sich zu Hause wenigstens ein rudimentäres Internet mitgelegt bekommt, dass man sich wie selbstverständlich an einer Wissensgesellschaft beteiligen kann.
Das würde ich auch von meinen Steuern bezahlen, weil das sehe ich einfach als Gleichberechtigung, wie gesagt, in der heute informierten und zu informierenden Welt.
Und sollte dann jeder, der irgendwie dieses Internet nach Hause gelegt bekommt, sollte ja auch irgendwie komplett freies, ungefälliges Internet haben dürfen und dort dann von, sagen wir mal, vom Staat gesponserten Internet auch Bithorn benutzen dürfen?
Eigentlich ja, wird aber schwierig zu finanzieren sein und auch wahrscheinlich auch den meisten WLAN schwierig zu kommunizieren sein. Warum denn jemand, der sich jetzt nicht beteiligt und dafür zahlt, dann volles Internet bekommen soll? Auf der anderen Seite muss man natürlich auch sehen, dass einige Dienste durchaus funktionieren, wenn sie ein bisschen langsamer sind, wie eben das Beispiel Bitteron schon war. Andere Dienste, wie vorhin das Beispiel z. Voice over IP war oder Videokonferenzsysteme, die funktionieren eben nicht, wenn dann eine Verzögerung von 5 Sekunden drin ist. Das müsste man dann abwägen, wo denn da wieder das Problem ist, dass man da wieder aufpassen muss, dass sich dann niemand mit politischen oder wirtschaftlichen Interessen einklingt.
Das ist ein spannender Punkt, den man noch gar nicht betrachtet hier haben, dass natürlich nicht nur ISPs, die dort wirtschaftliche Interessen haben, die Netzneutralität unterminieren, sondern dass auch die Politik jetzt mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder mit den Netzsperren auch ganz krass eingreifend in die Netzneutralität.
Das ist auch mal eins der Verkaufsargumente für so Paketklassifizierungs-Hardware, dass man da zum einen den Datenverkehr durchreduzieren kann, aber auch, und das ist ein Werbeargument, entsprechende Richtlinien rechtlicher Art und Weise umsetzen kann, also Internet-Sperren usw. Das hört ja nicht bei Namensauflösungen blockieren und durch eine Stoppseite ersetzen auf, sondern das wird in nicht allzu ferner Zeit sicherlich auf der Schiene auch weitergehen.
Genau, und da fängt dann das Aufrüsten wieder an, dass wegen der Tor benutzt wird. Dann werden vielleicht in Deutschland irgendwann die Toraufgangspunkte genauso blockiert wie in China neuerdings. Dann denken sich die Benutzer da wieder was aus. Ich denke auch nicht, dass man da eine Chance hat, dagegen anzutreten, weil da hat man eine riesige Gemeinschaft von Leuten, die zum Teil auch sehr technisch bewandert sind, die sich dann irgendwas passendes ausdenken und wieder dazu umgehen. Wo wir später wieder beim Punkt sind, das Aufrüsten wird das Internet kaputt machen.
Ok, Björn möchte also eine Netzneutralität und vor allem deshalb, weil er Angst hat, dass sonst die technisch versierten User das ganze Internet kaputt machen, wenn sie dagegen ankämpfen, dass das Netz nicht mehr so richtig doll neutral ist. Die Leitungen sind jetzt ganz schön dick, weil anscheinend wollte alle irgendwie neutrales Netz. Wenn jetzt jemand vom Radio endgeredet ist und sie denken, es stimmt doch gar nicht, so ein kontrolliertes Netz, das wäre doch super, dann kriege ich wenigstens keine Spam-Mits mehr. Ihr könnt durchaus auch ja anrufen, 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer dafür. Hallo Nils.
Hallo.
Du bist für ein intensives Netz, für ein uneutrales.
Also man sieht ja schon bei den Mobilfunkanbietern, dass die gerade beim mobilen Internet versuchen, das Netz zu gestalten, sei es nun Sperren von Voice over IP oder in den Verträgen reinzuschreiben, dass Instant Messaging nicht erlaubt ist oder dass beim iPhone das Tethering nicht erlaubt ist, in bestimmten Verträgen und in anderen Verträgen.
So und jetzt, wie jeder Mensch, der hier ein Wort sagt, was möglicherweise nicht verstanden wird, muss jetzt iPhone Tethering erklären?
Tethering ist quasi, ich mein Handy als modern benutzen kann.
Okay, das wird halt von manchen Anbietern verboten.
Okay Nils, aber du meinst, dass dein ISP einfach nur ein Kabel ist, ja? Aber die Wahrheit ist doch einfach, wäre er wirklich nur ein Kabel, dann hättest du bei dir zu Hause so einige Dinge deutlich weniger schnell da. Das heißt, dass es ja so Firmen gibt, bei denen du breitbandige Angebote nutzt, wie z. Filme runterlädst und die ganzen Trailer, die Apple z. B anbietet oder Musik aus dem Internet, die werden ja direkt von Servern, die bei deinem ISP schon stehen, dir nach Hause geliefert. Das heißt, dein ISP macht nicht einfach nur ein bisschen Datentransfer, sondern der sorgt auch aktiv dafür, dass du ein flauschiges Fahrgefühl hast, dass du häufig geklickte Inhalte schneller hast, als wenn du sie dann direkt einmal durchs ganze Internet, meiner Wege, aus Amerika holen müsstest. Also er ist aus Gründen, die auch vielleicht dir ganz genehm sind, natürlich nicht neutral. Und das Problem dabei ist zu bestimmen, wann er dort im Einklang mit deinen Interessen handelt und wann er irgendwie im Einklang mit seinen Interessen handelt.
Naja, dann müsst ihr es aber zumindest transparent darstellen.
Warum? Für dich ist ja der Effekt eigentlich derselbe. Wenn du die Filme aus Amerika runterlädst und dieselben Filme eigentlich auch bei deinem ISP bekommst, dann spart ihr eher den Traffic beim Peering. Und du hast die Filme schneller da, da schneiden sich dann eure Interessen.
Naja, die Frage ist ja, er müsste ja dann zumindest darstellen, was er denn schneller ausliefert und was nicht z. Also wenn es um echte Netzneutralität geht. Einfach mal, weil er ja grundsätzlich dann entscheiden, also wenn er mehr als nur das Kabel sein will, grundsätzlich entscheiden kann, was er mir dann ausliefert. Und ich denke, dass das nicht richtig ist. Am Schluss interessiert mich ja nur, dass die Daten bei mir ankommen. Und zwar möglichst gleichberechtigt, wenn ich das sehen kann.
Ich denke, dass du die Filme auch zehn Minuten auf einen Zehn-Sekunden-Clip warten möchtest oder dass du einfach sofort gucken möchtest. Welchen ASP wäre dir der lieber?
Naja, schon der, bei dem ich es mir sofort angucken kann. Aber trotzdem sollte er es halt transparent darstellen. Die Frage ist außerdem, was cached der denn? Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass er einmal komplett YouTube runtercached.
Naja, da gibt es Firmen, z. Akamai oder Limelight Networks, die stellen in allen möglichen Ländern und in jede Hundehütte ihre Server mit vielen Platten drin. Da ist so Content von YouTube und dergleichen oder...
Aber Akamai ist dann nicht mein ASP.
Richtig, aber Akamai kann sich mit deinem ASP verständigen, dass die dort Server hinstellen. Dann tragen die Kosten, je nachdem, wie groß dein ASP ist und wie attraktiv das für so ein Content Distribution Network ist, teilen sich dir die Kosten oder dein ASP übernimmt das ganz. Also je nachdem, wie wichtig das ist, dass die Nutzer ein angehnendes Fahrgefühl haben, kümmern die sich da weniger und mehr darum. Das nächste Problem ist, so ein Internet Service Provider verkauft dir ja deine 16 MBit, 50 MBit, 100 MBit, was auch immer die Zukunft noch beringen mag, zu einem wesentlich günstigeren Preis, als er das einkauft, weil er in der Mischkalkulation fährt, weil einfach in so einem Breitbandnetz nie alle User gleichzeitig die gesamte Bandbreite ausfüllen. Die Frage ist dann, wie kalkuliert so ein Internet Service Provider, wenn er jetzt sieht, seine Bandbreite wird knapp keiner ausbauen, aber wenn dann datenhungrige Dienste wie BitTorrent usw. dazu kommen, muss er das irgendwie noch mit der monatlichen Grundgebühr in Einklang bringen, die er dir abverlangt? Ich meine, du möchtest sicher auch nicht für deine 16 MBit, die du zu Hause bekommen kannst, die 4-5 Euro pro MBit zahlen, die dein Internet Service Provider auf dem Internet schlägt.
Wenn ich mal stabil meine 16 MBit kriegen würde, dann würde ich eventuell auch noch bereit sein, dafür zu zahlen. Also ich sehe es ja auch zum Beispiel, da ich mir keinen VDSL hole, weil ich weiß, dass ich die 50 MBit eh am Schluss nicht bekomme, weil ich kaum einen Server habe, der es mir überhaupt bietet, der ich so viel runterladen kann, das sehe ich an der Uni.
Dann ist eine spannende Sache mit der Telekom, mit den 50 MBit. Die Telekom ist in einer interessanten Position, dass sie ziemlich viele Nutzer hat, die Breitbandzugänge haben und dass sie ziemlich viel ankommende Bandbreite hat. Wenn man jetzt Server betreibt und sozusagen Content Network ist, also ein Netz aus dem Daten rausgehen, dann sagen die meisten Internet-Service-Provider, ja, peeren wir. Dann zahlen wir irgendwie, wir zahlen die Hälfte ihr Zeit, die Hälfte für die Verbindung und tauschen unseren Datentransfer kostenfrei aus. Die Telekom macht das z. B nicht. Die Telekom zwingt indirekt Netze dazu, dafür, dass man zu ihren Kunden Daten übertragen kann, Geld zu zahlen. Also die Verlangenen für jedes Anbiet, was in ihr Netz geht, Geld. Das ist auch ein Punkt, wo Netzneutralität eine Frage ist. Da haben wir heute schon seit mehreren Jahren eben einen Telco, der die Hand dafür aufhält, dass er Kunden hat, die Bandbreite zur Verfügung haben.
Jetzt mal an dieser Stelle kurz sagen, weil ja auch noch die anderen Leute mitmachen wollen. Wir waren an einem Punkt angekommen, das einerseits so ist, dass Internet-Service-Provider etwas machen, was uns eigentlich allen zugutekommt, nämlich bestimmte Inhalte, die viel gebraucht werden, werden direkt vor Ort dann nicht mal gelagert und können dann sehr schnell abgerufen werden. Das ist zwar eine Einschränkung der Netzneutralität, aber im Prinzip profitiert jeder davon. Wäre das dann okay?
Das Ding ist ja, dass der Internet-Provider gleichzeitig auch von profitiert, indem er Bandbreitenkosten spart.
Ja klar, aber der User hat aber dadurch sozusagen keine Nachteile.
Dass er Inhalte casht?
Dass er Inhalte casht, an sich ist es okay. Man muss halt auch dabei beachten, dass der Internet-Provider genauso seine Vorteile von zieht. Weil er muss ja auch an den, ich weiß nicht genau, an wen er zahlt, ob er da direkt an den Dezix zahlt oder an wen auch immer, der er da zahlt, weil er auch die Leitung einkauft.
Okay, aber der Pum?
Er gibt sie ja nur weiter. Also die Frage ist ja, wie viel er einschränkt. Wenn er mir sagt, du darfst ein Protokoll nicht benutzen oder du darfst ganze Dienste nicht benutzen, dann ist das ja mehr als nur mein Videoclip kommt später.
Ja, das stimmt. Also der Punkt, um den es jetzt gerade so ein bisschen ging, war, es gibt halt bestimmte Dinge, wo die Netzneutralität eingeschränkt wird. Also, dass alle Daten nur genau so ausgeliefert werden, wie sie angefragt worden sind, die uns allen zu Guten kommen und die vielleicht eine ganz gute Idee sind. Ihr seid im Chaosradio. Es ist letzte Mittwoch im Monat. Es ist fast um elf. Deswegen passiert jetzt das hier. Blümchen. Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenwieseninhalte, Blümchenw Noch mal mit dem lustigen Modemgeräusch, Chaosradio.
Heute um Netzneutralität. Dass irgendwie ein paar Informationen, die du von irgendwo abrufst, unverändert und mit der gleichen Geschwindigkeit von überall bei dir ankommen.
Und die meisten Hörer und auch der Chaos Computer Club, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist für Netzneutralität. Also Daten sollen genauso angeliefert werden, wie sie angefragt sind.
Gegen Netzbefangenheit.
Aber wir haben auch schon festgestellt, es gibt bestimmte Arten von Nicht-Netzneutralität und Netzbefangenheit, die uns zugutekommen, nämlich immer dann, wenn uns Inhalte schneller angeliefert werden. Was ihr davon haltet, könnt ihr uns selber sagen.
Jetzt anrufen!
0331 70 97 110 Und wenn ihr euch die Finger wund wählt, gönnen wir uns eine kleine Pause mit den Neon Trees Girls and Boys in School. Neon Trees, Girls and Boys in School. Und als ich nach Musikwünschen für diese Sendung gefragt habe, hieß es Spiel Muse, Spiel was vom neuen Album Resistance, hat der Erdgeist gesagt, wollen wir nicht eigentlich nur Musik spielen, die es auch im Netz gibt, also die man sich so runterziehen kann. Ja, YouTube zählt nicht als runterladen, was ich gemacht habe. Ich habe mal geguckt, was klingt denn wie Muse und hat mir Record-Level, die Neon Trees vorgeschlagen. Ich finde das in der Tat, die sind schon ganz okay. Erdgeist verrollt die Augen, es ist nicht Muse, das kann nicht sein, aber ich bin da vielleicht nicht ganz so neutral. Ihr seid beim Chaosradio, es geht um Netzneutralität, aber weil es auch das Chaosradio ist, wo der Chaos Computer Club am Start ist, bin ich gerade gebeten worden, jetzt noch eine kurze Pause zu machen, um Dinge anzukündigen, die für den Chaos Computer Club ganz wichtig sind und bei denen euch gerne dabei haben will. Vielleicht sollte ich dem Menschen, der das Ansagen will, auch das Mikrofon aufmachen.
Ja, es gibt wieder verschiedene Chaos-Veranstaltungen, auf die wir gerne hinweisen werden. Es kommt also jetzt der Werbeblock, jetzt am Wochenende in Dresden, das ist ja sozusagen Vorort von Brandenburg, finden die Datenspuren statt. Dort in der Scheune in Dresdener Neustadt. Ja, und da gibt es so verschiedene Themen, Vorträge und Workshops, die alle was mit dem Netz zu tun haben, eben auch mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Netzzensur und so. Also das dürfte sehr interessant werden. Eintritt ist frei bzw. wird um Spenden gebeten. Außerdem gibt es wieder Datengärten in Berlin, im Chaos Computer Club Berlin in der Marienstraße 11, nämlich am 8. Oktober erzählt Erdgeist zusammen mit anderen was über OpenTracker. Und am 22. Oktober gibt es von Henry Story, das ist ein Gast aus Amerika, der gerade in Berlin ist, etwas über selbstgebasselte Social-Web-Systeme, also auch ganz interessant. Und dann gibt es natürlich zum Jahresende wieder den Kongress, den Chaos Communication Kongress im Berliner Kongresszentrum vom 27. bis 30. Dezember und das Motto...
Und noch einen ganz kleinen Termin, den sich so am Rande mitbekommen haben. Am Sonntag ist Chaos Radio Hörer-Treffen.
Das ist fast wie Chat-Treffen.
So sieht's aus.
Dann müssen wir da mal hin.
Kann man ja auch mal machen. So, das sind die Termine, die gibt's auch bestimmt noch mal online nachzulesen. Auf welcher eurer zahlreichen Internetseiten?
Zum Beispiel auf berlin.cde. Da gibt's dann auch gleich eine Unterseite mit Terminen, aber auf der Startseite steht's auch schon.
Alles klar, da könnt ihr noch mal nachklicken. Wir reden jetzt über Netzneutralität. Es geht darum, wie das Netz die Art behandelt, die ihr da durchschicken wollt. Ob es sagt, hey, ist mir egal, was du machst, ich mach das alles gleich schnell. Oder ob es sagt, oh, du machst gerade Dateien austauschen. Ach nö, das lassen wir mal lieber, mach mal ein bisschen langsamer. Martin hat eine Frage dazu, ob ein bestimmtes Ding, von dem er gehört hat, auch zu dem Thema Netzneutralität gehört. Hallo Martin.
Hi, und zwar gab es ja dieses Urteil in Frankreich, wo jemand komplett vom Internet ausgeschlossen wurde, weil er, glaube ich, Feilscheren übertrieben hat. Woll mich mal interessieren, ob das nicht auch irgendwie zum Thema Netzneutralität gehört, weil es ja für jeden nutzbar sein sollte.
Natürlich, also das ist kein Urteil, das war jetzt ein Gesetz, was verabschiedet worden ist, in dem eine Three-Strikes-Out-Regelung verabschiedet worden ist. Das heißt, wenn du dreimal beim Feilscheren aufgefallen bist, dann wird dir der Netzzugang einfach abgeknapst. Und das ist natürlich das ganz krasse Extrem zur Netzneutralität, wenn du einfach schlicht und klar kein Internet mehr zu Hause hast und gar nicht mehr am Internet teilnehmen kannst, weil du einfach dein Recht auf freien Datenaustausch im Netz wahrgenommen hast.
Und dem Provider wechseln hilft nicht oder so eine Scherzfin?
Nein, du kommst dann in eine Datenbank, da hat auch ein Richter dort entschieden und der macht, dass du nicht mehr am Internet teilnehmen darfst.
Also quasi liegen meine Daten bei jedem Provider vor. Sobald mein Name da irgendwie in der Datenbank auftaucht, leuchtet die rote Lampe und das heißt, der darf kein Internet haben.
Denen wird da schon was einfallen. Ich glaube, über die Details müssen wir uns da jetzt gar nicht ergehen, sondern es ist eigentlich das Prinzip, was da so pervers ist, dass einfach dort Menschen ein Sinnesorgan abgeschnitten wird. Das ist einfach eine Amputation, weil heutzutage natürlich das Internet einfach dein zusätzlicher Sinn ist, den der moderne Mensch hatte. Den kann man nicht einfach abtrennen, ohne wie schwere Schäden so hinterlassen.
Noch dazu ist die Frage, wie will man dem Nutzer nachweisen, dass er Firesharing betrieben hat. Das ist heutzutage schon so, dass es mehr als dürftig ist, was da als Beweise vorgelegt wird. Und wenn drei ausreichen, um einem das Internet auszumachen, das sind irgendwie drei E-Mails von einer Anwaltskanzlei, die sich da Ausbildungen hat, für Rechteinhaber mehr zu verschicken.
Es geht nicht so einfach. Es muss ein Richterentscheid gefällt werden. Das heißt, es wird da richtig verhandelt und so. Und dann wird das Internet gesperrt. In Frankreich ist halt alles ein bisschen kontrollierter als hier. Ich habe das selber erlebt. Ich war vor einiger Zeit als Gast an der Uni in Frankreich. Und da habe ich eben so das normale Internet genießen dürfen, was man da so als Student und so genießen kann. Und auch als Mitarbeiter. Ja, und da gibt es halt nur Port 80. Also ich kann gerade mal im Internet surfen und sonst geht gar nichts. Also es ist nichts anderes, steht zur Verfügung. Das gab es allerdings.
Also reden wir jetzt von dem Netzwerk innerhalb der Uni?
Ja, wenn ich in der Uni, vom Campus aus, in so einem Pool ins Internet will, dann geht halt nur das. Oder auch mit meinem Rechner. Den kann ich überall anstöpseln, das geht halt schon, in der Bibliothek und so. Aber dann kriege ich halt wirklich nur eben Port 80 und eben auch 443.
Also das heißt normale Webseite aufrufen?
Normale Webseite.
Gibt es irgendeinen Grund, wie ihr einen Internetkurs, sag ich mal, von der Regierung aus vertreten oder rechtfertigen?
Ja, da gab es heute sogar ein Statement von der Bundesnetzagentur, die sich zu Netzneutralität bekannt hat im Rahmen des Eco-Kongresses. Nee, gestern war das, 29. Star ist auf Haise. Eco-Kongress, Bundesnetzagentur bekennt sich zur Netzneutralität, weil die natürlich auch die Debatte in den USA beobachtet haben, wo das mit der Netzneutralität schon so ein bisschen weiter und auch teilweise in den Mainstream-Medien ist, weil da große Netzbetreiber von so Diensten wie Amazon oder Google angefangen haben, sozusagen Datenmaut zu verlangen. Und ja, also da gibt es schon ein freundliches Statement, dass das ganz gut ist, dass diese Debatte mal anfängt und dass man sich damit mal auseinandersetzt mit dieser Netzneutralität.
Nun weiß man nicht, wie es in Deutschland weitergeht, ne? Also wir haben im Augenblick eine Regierungskoalition, von der die eine Hälfte das Netz vom Schmutz befreien will und die andere das Netz zum großen Geschäftsmodell ausbauen will. Und das ist eigentlich eine schwierige Kombination, wenn es um Netzneutralität geht.
Aber jetzt direkt, wie die Franzosen sozusagen ihre Netzpolitik vertreten und warum das so rechtlich fertig ist, ich meine jemanden vom Internet loszustöpseln, ich habe so einen Urteil schon gefallen, ist für irgendjemand, ist ja schon ein krasser Eingriff in das Menschenrecht.
Letztendlich resultiert das aus der Diskussion mit den Urhebern, also Musikindustrie, Filmindustrie, die es halt gerne hätten, dass sowas nicht mehr illegal runtergeladen wird. Das ist natürlich auch eine Form von Netzneutralität, könnte man sagen. Aber da sind wir dann quasi wieder beim Thema Urheberrecht und das wäre dann wieder ein anderes Chaosradio, mal gucken, wann das wieder dran ist. Martin, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank und einen schönen Abend noch. Und dann haben wir einen anderen Martin und der hat sozusagen einen Vorschlag, wie man das lösen könnte mit der Netzneutralität. Hallo!
Ja, hallo.
So, erzähl mal, wie würdest du es machen?
Also das Thema ist ja gar nicht mal so uninteressant und zwar könnte man für verschiedene Usergruppen, nicht jedes Thema ist gleich interessant und zwar, keine Ahnung, der Musikliebhaber, den könnte man anbieten, dass der superschnell seine Musik bei, keine Ahnung, bei iTunes runterladen kann oder dass der Spieler seinen Anschluss extra vorkonfiguriert wird, damit er superschnell spielen kann, damit er jedem immer einen perfekten Ping hat oder so, keine Ahnung und das halte ich für gar nicht mal so eine schlechte Idee, aber naja, hat auch immer die ganze Sache immer auf den Haken gehemmt.
Na du würdest aber sagen, es wäre okay, wenn man sich den Internetanschluss zulegt, dann kann man halt ankreuzen, ich möchte Videofilme gucken und spielen und dann sagt der Internetanbieter, okay, das kostet dann so und so viel und wenn man halt ein komplett freies Internet haben will, dann wird das halt richtig teuer einfach.
Ja, das soll man immer abwägen, also wie viel bezahlt man jetzt momentan für einen sozusagen noch, ich weiß ja nicht, ob das jetzt schon gemacht wird, so wie ich das gehört hab, ja, ungefähr wahrscheinlich 30 Euro im Monat für einen Internetanschluss und wenn der dann plötzlich für einen ungefiltert ist und plötzlich 50 Euro bezahlen soll, dann würde ich das nicht eingehen.
Du meinst also, dass man für ein neutrales Netz einen gewissen Grundbetrag bezahlt und wenn man dann diese Netzneutralität nicht möchte, sondern bestimmte Dienste bevorzugt, einen kleinen Obolus oben drauf legen?
Ja genau, so wie das z. B mit dem Fastpass war, was ja jetzt bei Telekom ja weggefallen ist, für die kleineren Anschlüsse, dass man dann eben so 5 Euro bezahlt, damit man dann eben so eine Option wieder hat, damit eben Spiele schneller laufen oder Downloads nicht gedrosselt werden oder einer, der viel uploadet ins Internet sozusagen auf seine eigene Seite oder so. Dass der da nicht eingeschränkt wird, so was könnte man ja dann machen.
Jetzt sagt im Chat gerade jemand, naja, aber dann müsste man dem Internetprovider quasi verraten, was man so vorhat im Internet. Dann müsste man wieder ganz schön viel über sich verraten.
Das wäre dir aber egal.
Ja gut, also über illegale Aktivitäten, da brauchen wir ja nicht überreden.
Vielleicht gibt es so eine Extra-Checkliste auf dem Internetformular, so ich würde gerne illegale Musik runterladen.
Das ist eine Unerwünscht.
Muss ja nicht immer illegal sein. Es gibt ja auch durchaus...
Aber für dich wäre es halt eine Lösung, dass man sagt, hier ihr kriegt alles selbe Internet, wenn ihr extra wollt, könnt ihr extra bezahlen.
Das ist ein Ansatz, den man da vielleicht machen könnte, aber generell so was einfach so von heute auf morgen zu machen, ohne vielleicht seine keine Ahnung, seine Nutzer mal zu fragen, wie sie es gerne hätten, das wäre dann vielleicht schon mal ganz schön.
Alles klar, Martin, vielen Dank. Man könnte ja schon verschiedene Preismodelle machen, aber vorher sollten die großen Firmen mal ihre Nutzer fragen. Ich weiß nicht genau, wann das passiert.
Naja, das mit dem Nutzerdialog und den Netzbetreibern, das hat man ja am Chaoses Vodafone gesehen, dass das nicht so gut funktioniert.
Was war da genau los?
Na, es gab von Vodafone so eine Marketing-Kampagne, wo sie sich Blogger vor den Kahn spannen wollten. Das ist so ein bisschen daneben gegangen, die fanden das nicht so lustig.
Ah, es gibt diese Werbekampagne immer noch zu sehen, hat mir jemand erzählt, aber jetzt nur noch ohne Blogger. Also ganz ohne die ganzen bekannten Blogger. Es gibt irgendwie jeden Typ, der vom hoch raus springt und sich selbst fotografiert, der ist noch zu sehen, aber die ganzen Blogger... Nein, eben nicht. Das heißt, ich sag immer unbekannter. Tim will uns noch was zur Netzneutralität erzählen, die er erlebt hat.
Hallo, guten Abend. Ja, also erst mal bin ich auch auf jeden Fall für Informationsfreiheit, freies Internet. Und im Allgemeinen, muss ich sagen, finde ich das schon beängstigend, wie sich das halt alles entwickelt. So mein halt Internetanbieter... Ich weiß nicht, wie ich Namen nennen darf.
Wenn du jetzt also nicht anfängst, die Tarife anzupreisen...
Nein, nein, es geht jetzt zum Beispiel darum, ich hatte mir in meiner Wohnung halt einen Handysanschluss geholt und hab mich dann gefreut, schließe das an und merke, verdammt, ich komme mit meinem iPhone gar nicht ins Netz. Und dann hab ich gemerkt, ich bin da nicht ziemlich beschnitten dabei und dabei. Hab mir das zwar im Endeffekt selber zurechtgebastelt und hatte dann so mein freies Internet zu Hause mit meinen Geräten nicht benutzen wollte.
Und du kamst mit dem iPhone nicht in dein Netz über Alice?
Nein, es gab so ein Sphiron-Modem und dafür musste man auf jeden Fall PPOE anwenden, um halt reinzukommen. Also es war auf jeden Fall, musste man halt, musste man sich halt direkt mit den Daten einführen, das konnte das iPhone halt damals nicht.
Ach, du hattest keinen Router davor stehen gehabt, verstehe ich.
Nee, ich hab's mir nachher gesagt. Ich hab's von Alice gekriegt so und ich dachte halt, ich kann so frei los surfen. Auf jeden Fall war ich da halt auch schon gebremst mit der Informationsfreiheit, aber es wird halt auf vielen Fronten, finde ich, gekämpft.
Z.
B wenn man bei B-Pod kaufen will, ist wieder ein Content angeboten, den man dann nicht kaufen kann, weil man nicht aus den USA kommt. Oder man surft halt rum und guckt halt einfach mal aus Interesse beim BKA, ob man bei dem Heißgesuchten dabei ist und wird dann beschattet, wie sich das dann später rausgestellt hat. Oder z. B wenn man bei A-Kor ist, dass dann halt YouPorn gesperrt wird.
Bei A-Kor?
Das war mal. Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch aktuell ist, aber es wurden halt so einige Porno-Contents und sonstige Sachen gesperrt. Oder jetzt aktuell, ich weiß jetzt nicht, war das Yahoo? Ich glaube, Yahoo, das kann man bei Wikileaks nachgucken. Da wurden halt sehr merkwürdige Inhalte gesperrt, halt auch Haise-Artikel und sonstiges. Und ich finde, wenn man sich das halt alles in groben so anguckt, dann auch mit den Netzsperren muss man eigentlich schon ganz genau aufpassen, was man anklickt. Wenn ich mir dann vorstelle, dass ich einen Freund von mir einfach eine Tiny-Ul-Schecke mit irgendeiner Porno-Seite, die jetzt vielleicht gerade auf dem Index, oder was weiß ich, was steht aus Spaß, und der klickt da raus, dann hat er halt eher gleich den Salat an der Haken.
Okay, jetzt sind wir aber schon wieder bei, also gehört das noch zum Thema, so richtig?
Ja, es ging jetzt natürlich nicht um die Inhalte. Es ging im Endeffekt eigentlich nur darum, dass man sich eigentlich ziemlich genau Gedanken machen muss, was man mittlerweile anklicken soll. Ich nutze das Internet schon ziemlich lange und habe da früher immer sehr frei rumgeklickt und mir angeguckt, was ich wollte und runtergeladen.
Würdest du denn für ein Internet sozusagen, wo du einfach machen könntest, was du wolltest, und ganz sicher wäre es niemand guckt drauf, würdest du da mehr zahlen?
Ich finde das Recht auf Information, das ist ein Recht, das jeder haben sollte, und ich finde nicht, warum ich das besonders vergüten lassen sollte. Das wäre, ich weiß auch nicht, warum sollte ich für die Wahrheit mehr Geld zahlen?
Aber dann sozusagen wirst du ja quasi im Zeitwitzfall nicht mehr ins Netz gehen?
Ne, darauf kann ich nicht verzichten.
Okay, ich glaube, Tim steht da noch eine eher schwierige Zeit bevor, weil er nicht mehr Geld zahlen will, was vielleicht kommt, aber trotzdem unbedingt im Internet bleiben muss. Wir sind gespannt, wie das ausgeht. Bernd wollte auch noch was zur Netzneutralität erzählen, und zwar im besonderen Fall von Voice over IP.
Hallo, Bernd. Hallo, erstmal piratische Grüße aus Berlin. Es geht darum, dass es gab ja in den Schlagzeilen so was, dass dementsprechend T-Mobile und ich glaube O2 oder Vodafone, eins von beiden, die Voice over IP-Leitung, wenn man dementsprechend das UMTS nutzt, sich einfach wegsperrt oder die Ports sperrt oder so.
Das haben wir am Anfang der Sendung ja schon darüber diskutiert.
Das heißt jetzt aber nicht unbedingt, dass wir es nicht normal machen können. Okay, also es geht darum, dass wir sagen, wenn man Internet auf dem Handy hat, dass man dann keinen Voice over IP mehr machen darf. Aber das ist doch eigentlich verständlich, oder?
Oder zumindest eingeschränkt. Na ja, ich sag mal so, es ist eigentlich eine frei... Man bezahlt ja im Endeffekt dasselbe wie auf einer Festnetzleitung. Ja, oder teurer dementsprechend und kann gewisse Dienste nicht nutzen. Und ich bin der Meinung, das zählt einfach nicht als Netzneutralität, weil...
Na ja, aber jetzt verkaufen die Anbieter ja auch kein neutrales Netz, sondern die Anbieter sagen ganz klar, pass auf, wir verkaufen Internet auf dem Handy ohne Voice over IP und ohne Instant Messaging.
Ja, aber komischerweise andere Anbieter, z. B ich bin bei Plus, denen ist es dann mal so scheißegal.
Das ist dann der Punkt, wo du als Nutzer sozusagen mit deinem Geldbeutel abstimmen kannst und sagen, von dem Anbieter ist mir bekannt, die haben Netzneutralität, gebe ich mein Geld bei denen aus. Das ist das, was ich hoffe, dass in den Köpfen der Nutzer in Zukunft ein bisschen sich manifestiert, dass man sich auch anguckt, wie hält mein Anbieter das mit der Netzneutralität und sich dann da entsprechend entscheidet.
Ja, weil ich bin der Meinung, das sollte man einfühlen, dass dementsprechend alle Nutzer diese Inrichter haben.
Der Gedanke von Nimla ist natürlich, dass wenn die Leute darauf achten, dann werden die Provider immer weniger, die können sich das einfach nicht mehr leisten, nicht neutral zu sein.
Aber es gibt ja den Einen zu sagen, wir machen das gesetzlich, wie die Bundesnetzagentur sagt, Netzneutralität muss gewährt bleiben, wir sollten vielleicht mal eine Regelung finden. Aber es gibt ja andere Leute, die sagen, lasst es doch einfach den Markt regeln. Es wird immer irgendeinen Internetanbieter geben, der sagt, hier bei mir kriegt ihr das Netz ungefiltert und der wird dann schon so viele Leute ziehen, dass sie das irgendwann von selbst erledigt haben.
Ja, weil der Trend geht ja im Endeffekt dahin, dass dementsprechend das Internet nur noch meist mobile benutzt wird.
Naja, aber wie du gerade sagst, es gibt schon Anbieter, wo das geht, wo man trotzdem Skype nutzen kann und Voice-over-IP und was auch immer. Da wird sich das schon irgendwie der Zeit nach durchsetzen. Reicht das dann nicht, wenn man jetzt den Markt selber klären lässt? Ok, Bernd haben wir überzeugt, das geht alles klar. Ja, ich habe einfach auch ein bisschen zufrieden, auf jeden Fall. Wie seht ihr das? Reicht das, dass man den Markt das überlässt und sagt, pass auf, mach halt einfach so und Netzneutqualität wird schon früher oder später kommen, weil es einfach das bessere Produkt ist?
Ich weiß nicht, der Markt hat eigentlich bei so kritischer Infrastruktur immer ziemlich wenig Gutes geschaffen und meistens musste es die eine oder andere Art der Kontrolle des Staats geben, z. B durch die Bundesnetzagentur, die dort Auflagen auferlegt hat. Das sieht man an den roaming-Preisen, z. B hat der Markt auch in Europa das einfach nicht reguliert, dass es billig geworden ist, bis der Staat interveniert hat, weil er meinte, dass innerhalb der EU man nicht für das Übertreten an der Grenze beim Telefonieren bestraft werden soll und vorher haben einfach in so einem großen Kartell die Telefonieanbieter einfach das Geld gemolken, wo es ging.
Das Spannende wiederum ist dann aber auch, dass es von der Ale of Men mit so einem kleinen GSM-Anbieter gibt, der inzwischen prepaid SIM-Karten anbietet mit kostenfreiem Incoming-Roaming. Also das ist schon eine Frage der sanften Regulierung an der Stelle.
Also man muss glaube ich auf allen Ebenen arbeiten. Also natürlich ist es gut, wenn die Leute ein bisschen drauf achten und nicht gerade zu so einem Zensurprovider oder was auch immer gehen, sondern eben einen anderen dann wählen. Aber das alleine reicht natürlich nicht. Also es ist auch wichtig, dass man eben politisch aktiv ist und sagt, also wir wollen Netzneutralität. Also das muss einfach auch mal eine Forderung sein und nicht sagen, das wird der Markt schon irgendwie hinbekommen, denn der Markt wird vielleicht noch ganz andere Dinge hinbekommen und immer mehr irgendwie Sachen extra bezahlbar machen oder so. Also da würde ich wirklich nicht auf den Markt vertrauen. Aber ich würde mich auch nicht auf den Staat verlassen. Also der Staat wird es nicht regeln.
Müssen wir dann vielleicht einfach alle selber unser eigener Internet-Provider werden?
Das ist eben das Problem. Der Markt, was Internetzugang angeht, ist aufgeteilt auf einige wenige Anbieter, die sich da ziemlich viel rausnehmen können, weil sie einen großen Kundenstamm haben. Also in der Tat schon problematisch. Es ist kein Dutzend Internet-Anbieter, was 90 Prozent der Leute bedient. Und da einen Nischen-ISP in einer nicht netzneutralen Landschaft hinzustellen, das ist deutlich aufwendig. Also da ist schon die freundliche regulierende Kraft gefragt, die großen Anbieter mal so ein bisschen Richtung Netzneutralität zu stubsen.
Alles klar, also der Markt eine wird es anscheinend nicht richten. Wie das funktionieren kann, ob es vielleicht eine Regulierungsidee ist, das werden wir gleich besprechen, z. B mit Markus, der hier angerufen hat. Ihr könnt auch noch anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110, denn nach den Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr, die es dann gleich geben wird, reden wir noch eine halbe Stunde über Netzneutralität und vorher geben wir uns eine kleine Pause und erfreuen den Chat zur Sendung, den ihr auf fritz.de findet, wenn ihr da klickt, etwas Musik. Und die kommt von Entertainment for the Brain Net und zwar im Kraftfutter Mischwerk Remix Run.
Immer noch laut, immer noch englisch und immer noch alles andere als tot.
Präsentiert von Prince.
Nachrichten.
Mit Mario Bartsch.
Nach dem schweren Erdbeben vor der Insel Sumatra läuft die Hilfe für die Opfer an. Erste Mitarbeiter internationaler Organisationen sind im Einsatz, um Nothilfe zu leisten, teilte die Caritas mit. Einen Tag nach dem Seebeben im Südpazifik war das Erdbeben mit einer Stärke von 7, 6 auf der Richterskala auf den Westen der indonesischen Insel getroffen. Bisher sind mindestens 75 Menschen tot geborgen worden. Behörden befürchten aber tausende Opfer unter den Trümmern, weil viele Häuser eingestürzt sind. Die Zahl der Toten durch den Tsunami im Südpazifik gestern Abend wird inzwischen mit mehr als 120 angegeben. In Stuttgart wurde heute darüber beraten, wie Amokläufe an Schulen in Zukunft verhindert werden können. Ein Expertenteam hatte Vorschläge erarbeitet, wie Schulen sicherer gemacht werden sollen. Die Fachleute empfehlen zum Beispiel ein spezielles Türsystem für Klassenzimmer, bei dem sich im Ernstfall die Tür nur noch von innen öffnen lässt. Für Jugendliche wurde außerdem ein generelles Verbot von sogenannten Killerspielen vorgeschlagen. Ob die rund 80 Vorschläge auch umgesetzt werden, ist aber noch nicht klar. Bundestagsabgeordnete müssen komplett offenlegen, was sie nebenbei verdienen. Das hat das Bundesverwaltungsgericht in Leipzig entschieden und Klagen der SPD-Politiker Schili und Gröning abgewiesen. Sie hatten sich dagegen gewährt, dass Bundestagspräsident Lammert Honorare aus ihren Anwaltstätigkeiten auf Euro und Cent genau wissen wollte. Die Richter erklärten dies jedoch für rechtens. In der Fußball-Champions League hat Bayern München am Abend gegen Juventus Turin 0 zu 0 unentschieden gespielt. Außerdem unterlag Meister Wolfsburg bei Manchester United 1 zu 2. Heute Nacht ab und zu Regen bei tiefstwährenden zwischen 12 und 8 Grad. Am Tag dann erst viele Wolken und auch ein bisschen Regen. Nachmittags lockert dann etwas auf. Es sind aber einzelne Schauer möglich, das ganze bei Höchstwerten zwischen 13 und 15 Grad. A12 Frankfurt Oder Richtung Berlin zwischen Storke und Friedersdorf gefahrt durch ein defektes Fahrzeug auf der rechten Spur. Und A24 Hamburg Richtung Berlin zwischen Mainburg und Pritzwalk ist die Richtungsfahrbahn nach einem Unfall mit LKW gesperrt, da bitte auch vorsichtig ans Stau an, der heranfahren. Sonst überall. Gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann Fritz rund um Spremberg.
Mit Markus Richter im Chaos Radio und deswegen natürlich auch dem Chaos Computer Club. Ja, Gott, es wird Zeit, dass es vorbei ist. Aber eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch. Chaos Computer Club, heute in Gestalt von Erdgeist, Maha und Nibbler. Es geht um Netzneutralität, also kurz gesagt um Erdgeist was?
Um ein Netz, was sich dir gegenüber neutral verhält und den Daten, die du von dem Gesprächspartner abholen möchtest.
Das heißt, das Internet funktioniert so, dass alles das rauskommt, was man einfach so haben will. Aber das sehen manche Leute anders, z. Internet-Service-Provider. Also die Leute, die für euch das Internet besorgen, die denken nämlich, wenn man bestimmte Sachen langsamer macht oder gleich ganz verbietet, haben wir weniger Ärger damit. Dann können wir mehr Geld scheffeln und vielleicht den Leuten noch extra Kohle abknöpfen, wenn wir ihn doch wieder zur Verfügung stellen. Jetzt haben wir die ganze Zeit schon drüber geredet, ob es jetzt ein freies Netz geben muss oder vielleicht doch eins, was total kontrolliert ist oder so ein Zwischending. Und Markus hat angerufen, was sie auch noch machen können, 031 70 97 110 und hat eine Idee, wie wir das Netz regulieren könnten. Hallo Markus.
Hallo.
So, du hast eine Regulierungsidee.
Äh, ich hab eigentlich eher was zum Quality of Service noch mal. Eine Idee, wie man das umsetzen könnte, weil die ISPs ja das immer so vorschieben, ja wir müssen hier unser Voice-over-IP da schnell über die Leitung kriegen und deshalb dürft ihr kein Torrent machen. So, und wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, man kriegt halt seine Leitung, also ich für 30 Euro im Monat und kriegt da, was weiß ich, so zwei oder zwei Slots, so Quality of Service-Slots, was ich eingestuft habe, jeweils zwei in Hochmittel und Niedrig, so und dann kann man eben da seine Dienste, die man selber so gerade so braucht, wichtig da rein sortieren.
Okay, du sagst also sagen, der Service Provider gibt uns eine bestimmte Anzahl an Anwendungen, die wir sagen können, okay, du bist jetzt wichtig.
Genau, dass er sagt, okay, ich brauche jetzt, ich will jetzt spielen, will super schnell beide hier spielen und da kann ich eben sagen, okay, jetzt ist eben Spiel XY ganz oben auf der Liste, das muss jetzt ganz flink gehen. Und weil ich da eben in der Zeit nicht telefonieren will oder so, kann ich eben sagen, okay, alles, was weiß, wobei viel praktik ist, in die Mitte oder ganz runter oder je nachdem.
Ist es überhaupt praktikabel und oder vorstellbar?
Das ist im Prinzip Quality of Service, dass man dann seine Pakete ranschreibt, du bist wichtig, du bist nicht so wichtig, du bist überhaupt nicht wichtig. Also das ist durchaus was, was man realisieren kann, die Internet Service Provider beachten, nur diese Markierungen an den Paketen nicht.
Das ist ja die Frage sozusagen, wenn man das könnte, dann wäre die Frage so, ich sitze zu Hause und denke so, ich habe diese drei Gigabyte an Zerteporn, den ich jetzt unbedingt runterladen muss, und zwar in den nächsten fünf Minuten, ich schreibe an alle meine Pakete ran, das ist total wichtig. Wie will man denn sowas dann verhindern? Oder gar nicht?
Dann werden sie halt alle gleich behandelt.
Dann ist man aber sozusagen wieder am Anfang.
Dann ist man wieder am Anfang.
Das heißt, der Vorschlag, den Markus gemacht hat, funktioniert eigentlich nicht wirklich.
Nein, der funktioniert nur auf dem Stück der Leitung, was zu dir nach Hause geht und mehr oder weniger dann nach draußen. Aber das Geheimnis an dieser Paketklassifizierung, an dieser Packet-Inspection, ist ja, dass man den Datenverkehr wirklich in Tiefen analysiert. Dass man wirklich in die Pakete reinguckt und sagt, das ist der Dienst, das ist der Dienst. Und ja, das ist dann eben viel in der Netzneutralität, wenn man auf der Basis dessen, was da drin ist und wie man das...
Okay, naja, also sagen, da geht es um zwei verschiedene Sachen. Das heißt, Markus meint, wir machen es so, dass wir dem Provider sagen können, hier, mach mal bitte jetzt dieses eine Ding schneller. Und was du meinst, ist ja der Provider entscheidet für mich, was schneller ist und nicht.
Genau, das ist der Unterschied.
Aber sozusagen, und die Idee, die Markus hatte, ist aber demzufolge nicht durchsetzbar.
Nicht so richtig, ne?
Nicht so richtig. Okay, sorry Markus, da musst du dir nochmal was anderes ausdenken. Vielleicht hat Jan noch eine Idee, wie reguliert werden kann. Hallo Jan.
Hallo, ja, ich rufe vom iPhone aus an.
Das tut mir aber leid.
Und da ist man ja mit einigen Einschränkungen beim Netzzugang vertraut, die vielleicht jetzt nicht im Kern die Netzneutralität betreffen, aber damit verwandt sind. Und ich habe bisher so den Eindruck, wir sind uns ja alle einig, dass Netzneutralität was ganz Tolles ist. Aber die eigentliche Frage, und die ist in der Sendung, finde ich, ist ja noch nicht beantwortet worden, ist doch, wie gehen wir jetzt damit politisch um? Also am Sonntag waren ja Bundestagswahlen und da sind ja eher marktliberale Kräfte gewählt worden. Ja, und konkret meine Frage wäre, wer zum einen an die Vertreter des Chaos Computer Clubs was schlagen die denn eigentlich vor? Weil ich mich einfach persönlich frage, wie viel Regulierungen brauchen wir? Brauchen wir also, wenn ich mal meinen iPhone-Tarif nehme, als informierter Kunde weiß ich ja irgendwie, was da auf mich zukommt, kommt, dass da bestimmte Dinge, Stichwort Tethering ist eben schon gefallen, nicht funktionieren oder eingeschränkt funktionieren oder Extra-Kosten. Also mein Eindruck persönlich ist, dass es da eigentlich eher am mündigen Konsumenten scheitert, der einfach teilweise sich gar nicht auskennt und nicht weiß, dass bestimmte Dienste beispielsweise eingeschränkt werden können und wir nicht unbedingt eine ganz starke Regulierung brauchen, die jetzt die Netzneutralität gesetzlich vorschreibt.
Aber du sagst keine Regulierung?
Ich sage nicht keine Regulierung, aber ich mache mich ganz ehrlich, wie viel Regulierung ist nötig. Und ich bin gewiss kein FDP-Vertreter, sondern sogar Fördermitglied im Chaos Computer Club. Das kann ich allen Hörern mir auch empfehlen. Aber trotzdem, was für Regulierung ist eigentlich nötig? Also brauchen wir, reicht es aus, vielleicht irgendwie Backbones freizuhalten, also dargesetzlich zu regeln, dass das Netz jetzt in der Zugang neutral sein muss. Aber ist es nicht eigentlich sogar vielleicht im Sinne der Kunden, also verbraucherfreundlich zu sagen, naja, dass es eben Tarife gibt, in denen mein Netzzugang in irgendeiner Art und Weise eingeschränkt ist, aber dafür sind die dann eben billiger, weil der Markt das einfach entsprechend, also weil die Anbieter damit eben dann auch niedrigere Kosten haben.
Also könnte man es zusammenfassen mit, du möchtest Lida, kann alles haben, wenn er will, aber es ist durchaus okay, wenn andere Sachen auch angeboten werden.
Ja, möglicherweise. Also ich persönlich möchte eigentlich schon einen freien Netzzugang haben, also natürlich ärgert mich das, dass ich bei meinem iPhone irgendwie Skype nicht über andere Dienste, nicht über das Mobilfunknetz nutzen kann, aber ich habe ja als Kunde auch die Wahl und kann auch sagen, ich kaufe mir eben kein iPhone oder ich kaufe mir entsprechend lieber bei E+, irgendeinen Datentarif, der das möglich macht. Aber das setzt natürlich auch voraus, dass die Verbraucher entsprechend informiert sind.
An der Stelle zitiere ich vielleicht gerne eine Dame von der Bundesnetzagentur, das war heute ein Haise-Artikel, vielleicht hilft hier die Drohung mit einem inkompetenten Regulierer, um die Parteien an den Verhandlungstisch zurückzubringen. Das ist eigentlich schön formuliert, dass da der sanfte Druck sozusagen für eine Diskussion sorgt, die sei es zwischen den Anbietern, sei es zwischen Anbietern und Interessensträgern auf verschiedenen Seiten. Also es ist einfach ein Thema, was diskutiert werden muss, wo man nicht nur die Internet-Service-Provider an einem Tisch hat, sondern eben auch die Nutzer.
Jetzt aber, er hat sozusagen ja noch eine ganz konkrete Frage gehabt. Chaos Computer Club, wie viel Regulierung wollt ihr haben?
Na, vor der Regulierung steht erstmal der mündige Bürger. Es gibt in Deutschland einfach zur Netzneutralität noch keine gesellschaftliche Debatte. Da wird einfach mal für gegeben genommen, wie du am Anfang meintest, dass da das Internet schon aus der Wand kommt und dahinter ist dann diese schöne Blümchenwiese, auf der man rumtollen und die Daten einsammeln kann. Aber wer dort die Spieler sind, das verstehen die meisten Leute nicht. Und bevor es dort nicht die gesellschaftliche Debatte gibt, ist es schwer dort auch wieder bevormundend Forderungen aufzustellen. Also es muss am Ende eine Regulierung geben, das haben wir in anderen Bereichen gesehen. Aber bevor das Bewusstsein nicht geschärft ist, auch in der Öffentlichkeit, dass dort diese Neutralität eigentlich ein ziemlich wichtiges Gut ist und wie viel man bereit ist von dieser Neutralität für bestimmte Bequemlichkeit oder Geschwindigkeit in seinem Netz aufzugeben, das sollte dann später auch der Bürger oder Kunde in dem Fall selber entscheiden.
Also Punkt Nr. 1, die Leute sollen sich gefälligst informieren.
Wir brauchen sozusagen das Ökobewusstsein, mal war das da gekommen, das brauchen wir in Datenbewusstsein.
Wow, ich glaube, das ist ja schon wieder fast ein Thema für ein eigenes Chaosradio. Das Datenbewusstsein. Aber okay, also natürlich, ja, so sagen wir, wenn man politische Vorwürfe stellen will, brauchen wir noch viele Leute, aber habt ihr sozusagen trotzdem keinen Plan, wo es hingehen soll?
Das ist wirklich schwer, man, wir wissen halt, was wir nicht wollen. Es gibt schon so ein Internet, wo man sich das mal angucken kann, wie es aussieht, wenn es oll ist. Und es ist, viele Leute arbeiten inzwischen in Firmen, wo ihr ISP eigentlich ihr Arbeitgeber ist. D h. wo sie am Rechner rangesetzt werden, dort auch privat surfen können, aber der Arbeitgeber selber einen ziemlich dicken Daumen drauf hat, was da an Internet ankommt und was nicht. Oh, der Markus kennt das hier vom Stritz. Und da sieht man, dass der ISP dort eine ziemlich strikte Agenda hat. Der will sich viel Ärger vermeiden, der will viel Kosten sparen und der stellt eigentlich das Internet den Mitarbeitern als Werkzeug zu erledigen von beruflichen Aufgaben zur Verfügung und räumt dann, weil das irgendwie so allgemein so ist, dann auch für private Nutzung so ein bisschen E-Mail, so ein bisschen Nachrichtenseiten klicken, räumt dann dem Mitarbeiter ein, dieses Internet auch privat zu nutzen. Aber dieses Internet ist schon krass reguliert und auch zensiert. Und dort sieht man dann, wie es in eine Richtung gehen kann, wo dann wirklich Adminen sich mal austoben können und beschränken, was da der Nutzer macht.
Also die Leute, die sich jetzt rüber informieren, sollen sich einfach mal vorstellen, das ganze Internet sehe so aus wie bei euch auf Arbeit. Sie haben eine unzulängliche Seite. Sie haben eine mit falschen Inhalten gesperrte Seite angesurft. Bitte geben Sie Ihre Nutzerdaten ein, wenn Sie wirklich darauf zugreifen wollen. Das ist die Seite, die ich mal gesehen habe. Nicht hier woanders.
Na, es gibt irgendwie Entwicklungen mit dem elektronischen Personalausweis. Da muss man ganz toll aufpassen, dass nicht demnächst irgendwann, wenn das mit der Netzzensur da mal überhand nimmt, dass man dann, bevor man ins Internet darf, dort seinen Ehepaar irgendwo in die Tastatur legt und dann erst bestimmte Seiten freigeschaltet bekommt.
Also das ist das Worst-Case-Szenario, die schlimmste Situation, die ihr euch ausdenken könnt, was Netzneutralität angeht. Da soll es auf jeden Fall nicht hingehen.
Schlimmer geht natürlich immer, aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Das wollen wir auf gar keinen Fall. Okay, Jan, hat das irgendwie deine Frage beantwortet?
Ich bin jetzt auf der Straße und verkehre im Hintergrund. Insofern, dass ich jetzt weiß, dass auch der CCC noch nicht so richtig eine Position dazu hat, aber ich bin ja auch der Meinung, dass das Hauptmang oder nicht, dass unsere Politiker noch nicht in diesen Angelegenheiten Bescheid wissen.
Also wäre mein Vorschlag, alle Bürger informieren sich selbst und wenn sie sich alle informiert haben, informieren sie dann mal die Politiker, die auch endlich Bescheid wissen. Ich hoffe, das hilft dann. So, dann haben wir noch den Markus, das ist heute der Letzte, den ich fragen muss. Die waren erstaunlich große Anzahl an Markusen heute. Den letzte, den ich fragen will, frei ist Netz, ja oder nein?
Ja, ich bin natürlich für frei ist Netz. Aber was ein großes Problem für mich ist, ich bin so ein Dau quasi. Also da habe ich doch kein Problem, das zu sagen. Vielleicht ein Semi-Dau, weil mir die ein oder anderen Fachtermini schon geläufig sind.
Also für die, die jetzt nicht mal wissen, was ein Dau ist, kannst du die Abkürzung nochmal kurz erläutern?
Das schlimmste anzunehmender User. Also ich habe wirklich, wenn ich habe Freunde, die studieren Informatik oder sind Programmierer oder sonst was, wenn die sich untereinander unterhalten über irgendwelche Sachen, dann höre ich öfter auch einfach nur noch 11001 ein. Und da ist halt eben mein Problem. Ich kriege zwar schon viel mit und das interessiert mich ja auch viel. Also gerade, ich bin da auch über meine Kumpels dann halt eben ans Chaosradio und Chaosradio Express angekommen. Und als das dann so mit den Netzsperren anfing etc. da habe ich dann noch mal ein bisschen interessiert dazu gehört und habe auch mal viel nachgesurft. Das Problem ist, dass man unendlich viel Zeit investieren muss, um sich mal schlau zu machen. Ich glaube, es würden sich viel mehr Leute dafür interessieren, wenn sie wirklich mit einem kurzen Zeitaufwand sich über das Thema informieren können. Ich mache jetzt gerade eine Ausbildung zum Heilherzjungslehrer. Ich habe 90% Frauen in Akters. Wenn ich denen jetzt sage, euer Content, den ihr da kriegt, da kann euer Zugangsprovider machen mit, was er will. Der kann euch eben auch mal was nicht zeigen. Dann sagen die, naja, was bedeutet das eigentlich? Das ist eben die Sache.
Dann musst du da hinten nach plastischen Beispielen suchen, dass die konkurrierende Fiseurseite dann einfach nicht mehr aufzurufen ist.
Ja, ja, so was halt eben. Das ist eben die Sache. Plastische Beispiele sind immer gut, aber es wäre quasi so ein Dauch-Wiki. Das wäre echt so göttlich. Dann kann man einfach nur sagen, ja, ihr schaut einfach mal auf der Seite nach, die zeigen euch das jetzt mal plastisch. Ich hab's schon mal bei meiner Mutter mehr oder weniger geschafft, ich hab gesagt, hier, hört ihr einfach mal den Podcast an zum Thema Netzsperren. Der ist einfach ziemlich gut beschrieben. Da kann man schon selber so ein bisschen was raushören. Aber ich kann jetzt nicht von jedem immer verlangen, dass er sich so ein Podcast komplett durchhört, weil geht einfach nicht.
Man könnte aber auch als Gegenmeinung sagen, naja, es ist aber so irgendwie, fast jeder kommt im Computer in Kontakt. Das ist einfach mal Bürgerpflicht, dass sie sich informieren.
Ja, Bürgerpflicht hin und her.
Du hast ja auch Verkehrserziehungsunterricht mitgemacht, oder? Damit du nicht im Straßenverkehr überfahren wirst, wenn du da einfach nicht weißt, welche Frauen.
Jaja, aber gut, denn es gibt ja so gesehen kein Verkehrserziehungsunterricht fürs Internet. Da würde ich mich ja auch mal im Vorredner anschließen. Es gibt halt eben für alles schon irgendwelche Regeln etc. Und was ist mit dem, klar, mündige Bürger sollte es geben, deshalb informiere ich mich ja auch erstmal selber. Aber irgendwann hört auch die Motivation auf, sich selbst zu informieren, wenn man wirklich erstmal eine Menge an Wissen mitbringen muss, um da in dieses ganze Thema einzusteigen.
Na gut, aber wir können sagen, es ist ja quasi das Angebot, das hier auch gerade stattfindet, also das Chaosradio z. Du sagst ja von dir, du bist nicht so doll fit. Hast du die Sendung heute gehört?
Ja, ich habe sie jetzt komplett verfolgt. Zumal ich auch relativ lange bei euch in der Warteschlange hingekommen bin.
Und hast du jetzt die Sache mitbekommen, um es heute ging?
Ja natürlich, das war mir auch schon vorher gelaufen. Ich bin zufällig auch da drauf gestolpert, weil ich folge im Twitter dem Piraten NRW. Und da hat jemand verlinkt, ein Artikel von ZDNet, wo geschrieben wird, dass Wodafone über UMTS gewisse Inhalte sperrt oder dann auch eigene Inhalte anfeicht. Also schon Netzsperre in klein als Probelauf.
Du bist jetzt jemand, der nicht den Superplan hat, aber heute zugehört hat, interessiert, dass es verstanden hat. Wenn du es jetzt wiederum für die Leute erklärst, die nicht mal das Interesse aufbringen zuzuhören, dann sind wir schon wieder einen Schritt weiter.
Ja, aber manchmal ist es eben schwer, so etwas zu formulieren. Und dann so einfach mal so, ich kann euch das jetzt gerade nicht erklären, aber wenn es euch wirklich interessiert, dann guckt mal da und danach. Da ist es wirklich super beschrieben. Habe ich z. B wurde vorhin mal gerade genannt, auch irgendwie in der Sendung dieses OTR-Zeug. Habe ich vorher auch keine Ahnung von mir. Dann hier war mal ein Java-Account hier über Java CCCD angelegt und dann auch das Plugin in Pitkin reingehauen, weil da es einfach ein super Tutorial war. Da musste ich eigentlich quasi nur ablesen. Und das kann jeder Mensch.
Da hast du diesen Blog-Artikel gelesen in Chitola?
Genau, da habe ich diesen Blog-Artikel gelesen, an dem bin ich auch über einen Kumpel gekommen, der eben auch ein bisschen mehr Plan davon hat. Und der sagte, das ist super einfach. Guckt da drauf und das wirst du auf jeden Fall verstehen. Und sowas meinte ich eben so. Für da ist wirklich einfach so ein Wiki. Leute, ihr seid guckt drauf und ihr versteht, was eigentlich gerade mit euch passiert.
Alles klar, hoffen wir, dass das irgendwann sozusagen Realität wird. Aber es liegt natürlich ein bisschen an euch. Es gibt ja sozusagen jede Menge Hörer, die das Chaos-Radio hören, die sehr wohl fit sind und sehr wohl wissen, was abgeht, auch weit aus mehr, als wir heute geredet wurden. Und Markus, das ist glaube ich so eine Aufforderung, auch an die. Ich führ euch mal zusammen und erklär es auch denen, die es einfach noch nicht wissen. Wir hatten außerdem noch zwei Fragen aus dem Chat.
Genau, die würde ich einfach mal so relayen. Vielleicht macht Nibler, die ja beantworten, woher weiß man eigentlich überhaupt, dass man zu Hause ungefiltertes Internet hat.
Das ist relativ schwer. Sowas fällt einem natürlich erst auf, wenn es zu spät ist. Ja, kann man so nicht sagen. Das ist das Problem an dieser Netzneutralität, dass es wirklich sehr subtil ist. Dass man jetzt nicht wirklich weiß, ist die Seite, wo man da gerade zugreifen möchte, ist das Ding einfach so langsam, ist das für alle langsam, oder ist das nur für mich langsam, oder hat da mein Anbieter bestimmte Interessen.
Es gab vor zwei oder drei Jahren die große Diskussion um die Bundestrojane und die Art und Weise, wie diese in die Rechner der Beschuldigten dort reingebracht werden sollten. Da war eins der Möglichkeiten, während man an seinem hermischen Windows-PC sich hier so ein Programm runterlädt, einfach heimlich das Programm auszutauschen gegen irgendetwas anderes, was dann von Schäuble persönlich kommt. Dagegen gab es so ein Projekt, dass man alle ausführbaren Dateien, die man sich aus dem Internet runterlädt, oder dort eine Prüfsumme gegen einen dezentralen Dienst angucken kann. Dass es vielleicht genau ein Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerk gibt, in dem man die Netzneutralität durch Vergleich von die Seite sieht aber so aus, wenn ich von hier klicke und da stehen plötzlich auf der Nachrichtenseite andere Nachrichten drauf, wenn ich keine Ahnung vom Bild gesponsert bin im Internet.
Aber dazu brauche ich ja schon mal den Verdacht, dass was nicht in Ordnung ist.
Ja, was heißt denn nicht in Ordnung? Also bei der nicht in Ordnung impliziert ja immer, dass da irgendwie was Böses passiert. Und mein Anliegen war ja heute gewesen, dass der Verlust der Netzneutralität ja immer irgendwie so ein zweischneidiges Schwert ist. Auf der einen Seite möchte man irgendwie filtern, z. B wenn da Spam rausgefiltert wird, auf der anderen Seite möchte man nicht zensiert werden von irgendjemandem, der man nicht selber ist. Und diese Netzneutralität wird angeknabbert von allen Seiten, aus pragmatischen Gründen, aus finanziellen Gründen, aus politischen Gründen. Aber man soll sich dessen immer bewusst sein. Und deswegen will man wissen, dass da grad was nicht Neutrales passiert. Ob man es selber für schlimm findet oder nicht, muss man danach später für sich selbst entscheiden.
Du kannst irgendwie in den Supermarkt gehen, kannst dir Bio-Zeugs kaufen und weißt auch nicht wirklich, ob das von glücklichen Hühnern ist oder auch nicht.
Und da hatten wir noch eine Frage.
Genau, was mit der Netzneutralität im Licht der Pressefreiheit ist, habe ich ja auch grad angeschnitten, wenn man nämlich plötzlich im Supermarkt, neben der tollen Bild-Telefonkarte, jetzt irgendwie auch noch das Bild-Internet zu Hause bekommt und dann plötzlich irgendwie die linke Presse nicht mehr lesen kann oder irgendwie die linke Presse nur noch, wo Politiker-Namen durch andere Politiker-Namen ersetzt sind, lesen kann oder...
Aber das ist doch sozusagen eine Schreckensvision. Das ist doch nicht Realität.
Also bei uns in Deutschland.
Ich glaube, es gab da mal ein Kunstprojekt von so einem Studenten, der in seiner Universität genau so einen Filter installiert hat, wo einfach Politiker-Namen gegeneinander ausgetauscht worden sind und dann mal einen Tag nachgeguckt. Und ich weiß nicht, ob es den Leuten auffallen würde, wenn es auf dem Spiegel passieren würde.
Okay, es ist also technisch möglich, aber wir gehen jetzt mal nicht davon aus, dass es schon um einen großen Master-Up gemacht wird. Oder haben wir im Prinzip jetzt doch eine andere Regierung, und sind nur die falschen Namen in den Nachrichten gewesen.
Wo habt ihr denn eure Wahlergebnisse her?
Aber in der Tat eine spannende Frage. Wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit auch darüber geredet, was möglich wäre. Und die Tendenz war eindeutig, dass sozusagen Netzneutralität gewünscht ist. Die Frage ist, was ist denn technisch überhaupt möglich? Da kann Niblad noch ein bisschen aus dem Nähkästchen plaudern. Was die Leute, die uns die Steckdose ins Loch in die Wand machen, wo das Internet rauskommt, was können die denn überhaupt?
Da hört man das Argument, das ist doch so viel Datenverkehr, das kann man sich doch gar nicht. Und Computer sind doch gar nicht so schnell. Um mal ein paar Zahlen zu nennen, so ein großes Backbone wie das, was in Magenta da draußen steht, die haben so zwischen 300 und 600 Gigabit Datenumsatz, also 300 und 600 Gigabit pro Sekunde. Das hört sich jetzt erstmal noch viel an, aber wenn man sich anguckt, was die Hardware heutzutage leistet, man kriegt in einem so einen Schrank problemlos die Packet Inspection Gerät, was so seine 30, 40 Gigabit macht, und da hat man dann nur noch 10 Stück davon. Dadurch, dass der Datenverkehr so schön verteilt ist, verteilt man halt, lass es zählen, dass es 20 sein, bundesweit. Das kann sich so ein Internet Service Provider, wenn er größer ist, leisten. Und das wird er sich auch, weil es einfach von den Einsparungen her entsprechend was bringt.
Wait, darf ich es nochmal zusammenfassend nachfragen? Es ist so, dass du sagst, ein Internet Service Provider kann theoretisch, also es ist technisch machbar, jedes einzelne Paket, das er überträgt, durchleuchten und wissen, was da drin stattfindet.
Nicht nur durchleuchten, sondern richtig tief durchleuchten und irgendwie selbst state halten und sich merken, was da gerade bei so einem einzelnen Kunden losgeht und kann sich dann nach Filterregeln auch sogar noch einzelne raussuchen, die im Rauschen dann ganz besonders auffallen, die kurz ausleiten und dann nochmal gesondert noch tiefer behandeln.
Okay, aber er kann auf jeden Fall erstmal angucken, wie teuer ist sowas? Also in welchen Größenordnungen bewegen wir uns da?
Also schon im sechsstelligen Bereich für so ein Gerät, aber das ist verglichen mit dem, also um es in eine Relation zu setzen. Das, was ein Internet-Service-Provider für seine Router ausgibt, das packt er einfach nochmal obendrauf und dann hat er nicht nur Router, sondern auch welche, die Pakete klassifizieren können. Also das ist für sie jetzt kein Hinderungsgrund.
Das ist keine Hexerei sozusagen. Weißt du denn auch?
Noch dazu argumentieren diese Hersteller von so Hardware damit, dass man das ja eh braucht, um bestimmte Gesetze einhalten zu können, wie Internet sperren usw. Und dadurch, dass es zu einer gefühlt notwendigen Sache wird, nehmen die Internet-Service-Provider das natürlich umso lieber an, um dann auch noch so ein bisschen den Zusatzbonus zu haben, dass sie ihre User ein bisschen unter Kontrolle haben.
Und wenn es ihnen vielleicht sogar vom Staat bezahlt wird, weil es ja ihre gesetzliche Verpflichtung ist, dort die Netzsperren durchzusetzen.
wir können davon ausgehen, dass Deutschland schon rumsteht? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Okay, möglich ist ja also schon die Netzbefangenheit, wie das Gegenstück von Netzneutralität heißt. Damit ist das Chaosradio fast schon wieder zu Ende. Das nächste gibt es, wie gewohnt, in einem Monat. Und zwischendurch könnt ihr euch die Zeit mit anderen Sachen vertreiben. Das wird Maha kurz nochmal sagen.
Ja genau, also wir können uns direkt schon sehen im realen Leben bei den Datenspuren jetzt am kommenden Wochenende. Und natürlich dann am 8. Oktober, Donnerstag, zum Datengarten. Da geht es halt um BitTorrent und was das politisch und technisch bedeutet. Also insbesondere da eben auch offene Systeme. Und dann nochmal am 22. Oktober, wo es um das soziale Web geht. Also da können wir uns dann direkt sehen. Und ich möchte noch hinzufügen, also Markus, du hast vorhin gesagt, der Chaos Computer Club weiß noch nicht so genau, was er will.
Das hab ich nicht gesagt, das hat Jan gesagt.
Also es ist schon so, dass wir schon für freie Netze antreten und natürlich gegen die Netzbefangenheit und gegen Netzzensur.
Okay, ich möchte noch eine Sache anfügen, die nichts mit dem Chaos Computer Club zu tun hat, aber auch ungefähr ins Thema passt. Vom 8. bis 11. Oktober ist das NetAudio Festival. Und da kommt auch der Folgen her, der euch jetzt gleich verabschieden wird und wird dort am Freitagabend live auflegen. Das ist der letzte Song, den ich heute spiele. Danach kommt Smith'n'Smart im Night Flight und werden euch wahrscheinlich so lange mit Mash-ups bearbeiten, bis euch die Ohren bluten. Vorher gibt es noch mal Trekkie Birthday mit Dragan Espenschied und Website, ein gutes Stück Nordcore. Ich sage Tschüss zu Erdgeistmacher und Nibbler. Und wie gesagt, wenn ihr das nächste Mal dabei sein wollt, in einem Monat ist es wieder so weit.